this video is going viral and it shows
justin trudeau announce a
new legislation in canada that will
freeze importing buying or selling
handguns effectively banning them but
all but banning them well if you have
one fine but you can't get a new one you
can't bring a new one in you can't make
it you can't sell it you can't buy it
that's it
it is one of the most shocking moves
i've seen now we're not canada we're the
united states but the conversation is
certainly happening here in the u.s
where we've got people outright
prominent liberal personalities saying
ban all guns
and then other liberals are saying like
nobody wants to ban all the guns and i'm
like did you listen to what they just
said joe biden came out and said no one
should have a nine millimeter if you're
not familiar with that is it's like a
glock it's the handgun that cops use
it's extremely common it's probably one
of the most common uh handgun rounds and
it's small and he called it high caliber
and it'll blow out your lung nobody
should have it what here we go yeah if
someone shoots you in the lung with a
bullet it's going to destroy your lung
like what is it like blow it out of your
body oh that's what you say well that's
brilliant yeah maybe maybe some weapons
expert joe biden you let out two blasts
so we'll talk about that we've got a kid
in florida 10 years old was arrested for
for making a joke to his friend about
buying rifles
and they published the kids name and
face which is kind of shocking we've got
inflation is obviously the huge issue so
they can try and talk about guns all day
and night it's not really having a big
impact and i think we're gonna have to
talk about a couple things we got
paramount plus sponsoring a drag event
where a child is dancing on stage for
money from the audience and then we've
got the ethan klein story where last
week he called for a terror attack
against the nra convention before
quickly walking it back and telling
people not to do it he then went on to
tell people to commit
other acts of violence
and then had to walk back that back and
i don't even know what we're allowed to
explain because youtube might like
explaining what he said to do i don't
know if we can do that so we'll talk
about all that and i just want to shout
out uh matt walsh
because i watched i got an advanced
screener of what is a woman
it was so good it was absolutely
incredible they did an amazing job
editing that documentary so uh this is
this is not like a paid spot or anything
i just i got to watch it and i was
really impressed i thought it was really
good it was shocking it was funny and
that's gonna they're putting that out on
june 1st so just as an aside i'm i want
to talk about it so bad but i can't it's
not out yet anyway we're going to talk
about related things though joining us
we have a couple of journalists we have
cheryl atkinson hello
voice this time that's right would you
like to introduce yourself yes i am
i'm an independent journalist formerly
of cnn cbs pbs you name it local news
kind of on my own with a
sunday tv show we feed to 43 million
households every sunday now on various
affiliates around the country some right
on reformed mainstream journalists i'm
still the same it's everybody else
changed
we also have carrie sheffield hey
everybody good to be back thanks for
having me i love that today's memorial
day and i'm by the flag thank you very
much and i want to say thank you to all
our veterans and the men and i want to
say i was talking about this with lydia
earlier that real masculinity is not
toxic and it was real men who stormed
the beaches
and saved us in world war ii and uh we
owe them all a debt of gratitude and uh
i work for independent women's forum
we're a group that loves men a women's
group that loves men you can see that um
and we're working on some issues which
i'll get into to preserve women's rights
what is a man
an adult
all right then it's not that complicated
there you go
my name is seamus coughlin i have been
absent for about a week i am i'm back i
apologize for leaving i hope you can all
uh accept that apology and welcome me
back into your hearts because i've got
some good news i said no
oh okay well okay
oh no leaving too bad i'm imposing
myself
very good news we just launched
freedomtunes.com we officially have a
website up um the the public videos are
still being hosted from youtube but
we're working on moving that over and we
have a members only section where for
five bucks a month you will get one new
cartoon each week that the public
doesn't get only donors get you will
also get two behind-the-scenes videos
and you will be supporting the show
without needing to use patreon or some
other uh platform controlled by big tech
and there's a like five cartoons up
there already and a bunch of behind the
scenes stuff if you guys want to go
check that out including uh tim and i
doing some improv or actually that's
going to be up in in two days which one
was that weird the one where we like
basically came up with i gave you the
really offensive one
well i said improv i wouldn't go that
far when i sent him a rough script for
the fouchy cartoon we did with um with
the voicemails and we improved a bunch
of it it's really weird that's going to
be up in a couple days we improvised uh
fauci as a casting director in los
angeles but james no i did not yeah
blowing up the voicemail with the
mainstream media that was funny too
though that's awesome thank you thank
you and i am also here in the corner
with these two lovely ladies they're
excited to hear what they have to say
excited to hear about that this women's
uh bill that they're coming up with over
at the independent women's forum and
hopefully we can get into that this
evening absolutely before we get started
head over to timcast.com become a member
if you would like to support our work as
a member you'll get access to exclusive
segments from the tim cast irl podcast
those go up monday through thursday at
11 p.m we will have one for you
tonight and you'll also be supporting
all of our journalists who are working
on news around the clock and you'll be
supporting our infrastructure as we seek
to get away from big tech in silicon
valley and we have more conversations
more developments happening behind the
scenes of course i love to have those
announcements but uh we gotta we gotta
keep that stuff under wraps until
everything gets done so until then
support us if you'd like smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and now let's
read that first story
probably one of the most shocking
stories i've seen in a long time i
couldn't believe it when i saw this
video trudeau announced his national
plan to freeze importing buying or
selling handguns
now what really freaked me out about
this
is the way that he actually reads it let
me see if i i'm going to play this video
for you guys
let's see we're introducing legislation
to implement
freeze
on handgun ownership
what this means is that it will no
longer be possible to buy
sell
transfer or import
handguns
anywhere in canada
in other words
we're capping the market for handguns
i i think that's enough i don't want to
listen anymore that man yeah really but
the the the whispery
feathery way he's talk we're capping
handgun market he sounds like a bond
villain this is really creepy stuff
seeing all these people post online
about banning guns outright then they
come out and say nobody's trying to ban
your guns they're literally trying to
ban your guns and i think the important
context here is that i think we've seen
from history what happens every single
time guns get banned
well i don't understand yes what one has
to do with the other i'm certainly
interested in a rational discussion
about what needs to be done after these
tragedies i think a lot of people are
but to jump ahead to something like what
does this have to do with canada and
banning guns what does the tragedy in
texas have to do with that well i don't
think it does i think we're just seeing
the the the uh
the scale at which
this ideology wants to go so in the
united states there they know they can't
come out and say ban all the guns
because
nobody wants that inc
in the united states they know they
can't say that in canada
they can just do it i mean do they want
it in canada is that is different there
i can't speak for canadians he got a lot
of applause
he introduced the bill it was a bill so
we'll see what happens with the the
lawmakers but uh
yeah i mean it's it's just bizarre i
mean it's but it's still nothing new
under the sun i mean we've seen this
from other regimes and it is
fascism when the government wants to
take control of the firearms and take
them away from the people and what i
find hypocritical is is people who were
cheering you know the ukrainians all
arming themselves and just saying this
is a great thing uh you know
good for them for arming themselves you
know the hypocrisy they're posting
videos of child soldiers in ukraine
praising them and i'm just like man this
got dark real quick wow i mean isn't
ukraine the exact reason why some people
here say we should not be disarmed the
very thing that's happening to the
ukrainians it could be argued which is
they taught
right before the invasion of russia they
were actually training the local
citizens and how to use
you know their weapons in combat that
they already had
it almost makes the case for the
opposite of what they're arguing now
yeah exactly well and not just ukraine
the rioting that happened for months on
end in this country that was praised by
the left wing
they sit there and tell us that rioting
is an acceptable response when
politics doesn't go their way basically
and then they turn around and tell you
what a couple weeks to months later oh
you have no reason to own a firearm
there was a
during the george floyd riots there's a
guy in new york who called 9-1-1
because people were breaking into his
apartment building and fighting
and he said i need help
the dispatcher said sir let me send you
a therapist they said the city is under
attack what would you have us do yeah
good luck
i mean these people vote for this stuff
or they ignore they let it happen
and then when danger comes in aka and
you ain't got no one to count on so we
we saw here's the fascinating thing
about all of the gun control stuff is
that there are people currently arguing
for gun control when we just saw the
police in the uvalde incident not go in
but used their authority to stop the
parents from going in who were armed
which is what gun control is by the way
allowing the criminals to have guns but
preventing people who want to protect
themselves and their families from
having guns
and so
another take i saw from
a number of lefties was this proves that
the ar-15 is too dangerous because he
had one until the police were too afraid
to stop him firstly many of those
officers had ars but secondly if the
ar-15 is is too dangerous and terrifying
for a police officer to go up against
who's going to confiscate them how are
you going to ban them that's a great
question
well that's the the problem again with
the canadian proposal you're taking care
of something that's not happened yet
you're not taking care of the stuff that
they're complaining about now which is
the current ownership of guns there
can't be anything about that you know
what though like watching uh these
people
the these liberals try and ban guns
because i always say is like the
leftists want guns karl marx said to
keep guns the leftists typically want
them the funny thing about it is that
they're so ignorant of guns gun policy
gun mechanics
that they're actually losing now they
they win some things like maryland has
banned the m1a and it's like for what
reason what does that accomplish
it's ridiculous
but
36 states have permit less open carry 25
states have constitutional carry
florida is soon to be the 26th state
with constitutional carry so while the
liberals are screaming banning assault
weapons they can't define what assault
weapon is so nothing happens
and then on the right
they're enacting constitutional carry at
the state level and so now you have 36
states
permit-less open carry i mean that's
kind of crazy we we used to if you look
in the 80s
uh there was no concealed carry now
almost every single state has has to
allow concealed carry and 25 are
constitutional meaning you can just if
you live in the state you don't need a
permit at all you can conceal if you
want so they're losing and and no matter
how many times we scream that you're
ignorant of the laws they don't pay
attention so let them let them ban the
ridiculous nonsense and lose so here's
what's uh sick about it also when you're
talking about the soros funded
prosecutors who are going and picking
and choosing which laws they want to
enforce so you know in in los angeles or
new york or st louis you could
theoretically have uh you know one of
their prosecutors choose to to enforce
these gun laws um but then let you know
rapist walk free because we need
restorative justice and that's that's
disgusting throwing the book at things
that uh you know whatever political
marxist agenda you have
and then let's talk about what really
happens behind the scenes because i'm
really big on the notion that i've had
so many democrats and republicans
confess that what they do on capitol
hill they often agree on behind the
scenes but just not in front of
everybody
and when i broke the fast and furious
scandal about the government in essence
gun running drug guns to mexico
illegally went before they admitted they
were doing that
initially at cbs it was a democrat
leader of a committee
on the senate side that contacted me
that wanted to follow up on that story
as sometimes they do and they sense
there's a big story coming
and republicans also called me and i
shared public information that i had on
the story happy to make the story get
more information they can issue
subpoenas and interview people that i
can't get on camera
but the democrats quickly bowed out and
it was clear it confused me at the time
but in retrospect a decision had been
made and a staffer actually told me a
democrat staffer in the senate that this
was not a good issue for them because
they couldn't figure out how it played
with the gun control crowd and the gun
control issue
and that they had a lot of constituents
that support guns and they and i said
aren't some issues just this to me
wasn't a gun control issue this was the
government corruption and all kinds of
stuff i said aren't some issues bigger
than that debate but it's also covering
for obama too that was part of it too
well but the staff the staffers answer
was
you'd like to think so when i said
aren't some issues bigger than that then
well so so break down the fast and the
furious scandal for those that aren't
familiar
well this was the government got caught
through a whistleblower with atf i think
it was unprecedented that a sitting
federal agent came forward and spoke to
me on camera about it
they had been knowingly selling drug
guns putting them in the hands of the
mexican drug cartels and it was
misreported and is still frequently
misreported today
that there was sort of a sting operation
that they were trying to track the guns
to the bad cartel guys and lost track of
them they didn't attempt to track most
the guns that was the problem and they
were in essence arming the sinaloa
cartel down in mexico which isn't really
a stretch the imagination looking back
that we often take sides when there are
warring factions in countries and we
were choosing the sinaloa cartel
apparently over the zeta cartel which
were affiliated with terrorists and we
perceived as worse but regardless the
government
was using this issue of guns showing up
in mexico
not telling anybody we were moving them
there and saying look we need gun
control here in the united states
because we're selling guns and they're
ending up in mexico knowing all along
that they were putting them there this
was obama yeah under obama
and you know a lot those guns killed a
lot of people including a border patrol
agent that's why an agent stepped
forward because he had said and some of
the gun shops that knew this was
happening that atf was allowing it to
happen were saying
this is going to come back and shoot a
federal agent someone's going to get
killed with one of these guns and quite
a few people got killed with those guns
so to recap they would rather
arm mexican cartels who will kill us
atf uh agents while take away the guns
of law-abiding americans they'd rather
arm the taliban yeah yeah they'd rather
arm uh right
right they would what was it eight
billion dollars of equipment yeah
exactly i mean our government has this
very interesting habit of funding and
arming groups that end up killing
americans
sus
how did you find out it was a
whistleblower who came forward this to
this day i don't know who tipped me off
i got a
one paragraph tip in the mail a letter
that said
senator grassley is looking into this
and it briefly described something that
sounded plausible but so many of my
stories start out that way
and i called senator grassley's office i
knew he had a whistleblower
and grassley's office at the time would
not cooperate with me for various
reasons and i identified the
whistleblower his his girlfriend at the
time
called me because i did sort of a
generic story with what i knew because
that will stir the pot and bring out
other sources sometimes
she called me out of the blue and i
wrote down the number it came in on at
cbs and she said my boyfriend is
a source on this and he may want to talk
to you but not today
and he never called back she said he
might call the next day or two and i'd
written down the number and i called
back two days later when i really needed
that next story and knew there was
something serious going on
and i said i think i know who he is and
i had done enough poking around of who
the teams were that were working on
these issues in arizona and so on
and um he got on the phone with me and i
said i know you're probably john dodson
and he said whoa you know and it was and
it took a lot of doing to convince him
to go on camera as a sitting federal
agent he's been made to pay ever since
now they didn't fire him because
members of congress stepped in primarily
grassley's office every time he got
threatened
but he's been held out as a dog when he
should be the hero that everybody
emulates to blow the whistle when bad
stuff and murder
you know may be happening as a result of
things the government has done but
instead they've been he's been treated
just horribly and that's that's the
lesson that was sent out to other
federal agents that might blow the
whistle a good journalist should be a
conspiracy theorist to a certain degree
you have to be because you learn
that mo for me anyway most of what i
hear will not turn out to be true and i
try to disprove it on its face so when i
hear that the fast and furious tips i
start going about trying to disprove the
story and when i can't then i start
seeing if i can prove it so
you know but you do have to believe
that my my funny story is my husband's
former law enforcement he's a lawyer and
i would come home and tell him about a
tip i got or a story i'm working on over
the years and he would always go
that's just crazy that can't be true and
he said that about fast and furious and
i said
you know we always say that and then
sometimes they are you know well what i
think is also very upsetting is the
weapons flowing from the other direction
so a lot of the illegal firearms coming
up from mexico
but because the left doesn't want to
shut down our border those are coming
and circulating in our inner cities
especially you know for for you know
white liberals who say they care about
our inner cities and you know violence
for black americans and predominantly
minority neighborhoods but it's like but
they will not close down the border you
know and to me that's that's white
supremacy right you don't care about
black lives
when black lives are being killed by
illegal firearms from mexico where where
are the protests i never hear about this
i don't think it's it's it's should be
shocking anybody the people who advocate
for
slowing population growth
are
in favor of things that inhibit
population growth they're in favor of
children being sterilized they're in
favor of abortion and they're in favor
of destroying economies which stagnate
growth
well as you know again as a journalist
you like to poo poo stuff in me in the
early part of my career in particular
and then so many things turn out to be
true and i think of the
some someone's
something somebody tweeted not long ago
that became my favorite tweet which said
i have to find some new conspiracy
theories because all my old ones came
true
that's a good one yeah no it's
repeatedly happened with respect to i
mean many things surrounding covet 19
the lab leak hypothesis is one i bring
up pretty frequently but it's also
insane that it was so
straightforward and clear as an
explanation that it leaked from a
laboratory because the disease was first
discovered
near that laboratory near a virology
institute they're like no it came from a
bat and you're actually thousand miles
away a thousand miles away and you're
the crazy one if you don't believe that
gaslighting here's what trudeau said he
said
other than using firearms for sport
shooting and for hunting there is no
reason anyone in canada should need guns
in their everyday lives well
that's amazing what's the canadian
constitution say about guns if anything
i don't think it does not enough yeah
probably nothing
but you know
canada man oof
you know that's they vote for it
i think i think we're we're lucky in a
lot of ways that canada is doing what
they're doing so that we can see we get
to watch all the stuff that's going on
in that country well i'm just excited to
see what the truckers are going to do
next
i don't know is it
we'll see if this even makes it through
because it is just a bill but well i
thought also i thought his country was
just taken over by a bunch of like
supposedly fascist truckers who are like
honking their horns in the name of white
supremacy or something and he's like
there's no reason anyone would need to
protect themselves in this country yeah
exactly that's great both of those
things don't fit together yeah no
obviously it's because he knows that the
truckers were not actually dangerous
with respect to like the physical health
and safety of his citizens the way they
wanted to make it sound they were just
dangerous to the social order he was
seeking justice
and so was owning a firearm you know i
want to bring up the story uh about
ethan klein oh yeah ethan klein is a
podcaster he's particularly prominent
and
he recently called for a terror attack
against the nra and it's funny ethan
klein has been calling for you know gun
restrictions gun control but he's just
on his own podcast exemplified exactly
why people probably need guns for
self-defense
on his show last week youtuber ethan
klein calls for bombing of nra
conference
klein prefaced his calls for violence by
promoting sales of his new shirts which
reed and gun violence so uh he
immediately walks it back
he's i don't want to play it because i
think youtube
doesn't doesn't it doesn't allow this
stuff even in in this context there's a
few things i want to point out about
this
uh allies you know liberals in the media
are saying ethan klein was joking about
doing it
his wife says i feel hopeless like
there's nothing we can do i'm
paraphrasing then he says does anyone
know what's going on that nra conference
calls for extreme violence against it
his wife then says
that's what
is what really got me i'm like yo he
just said to told your audience of
millions of people to commit a terror
attack and you were like
no no no his producer apparently said
something and then he immediately walks
it back like okay no no don't do that
don't do that
apparently during the show as well he
told people to fire guns into the air
what and then when he was also told like
no don't do that the bolts come back
down he said okay well blanks just fire
blanks he called for uh sticking a a
piece of wood into the into the texas
governor's wheelchair to cause him
physical injury i guess the video ends
up getting taken down he's been
suspended from youtube for a week
and his immediate reaction was to say
you know he doesn't believe in violence
but republicans of the party have dead
children and that now they're harassing
missing them death threats and their
anti-semites so
it's it's mind-numbing you know that
this is the the current state of
politics
i genuinely i
seriously i wonder why it is people
would be entertained or like that they
would like that idea
yeah i don't know who would watch a show
like that and be like yes that's that's
a good thing and i will defend that
there's a lot of people apparently you
know isn't this the story of the past
six years the one side telling the other
what they shouldn't do but at the same
time advocating for
much the same themselves it just doesn't
doesn't make a lot of sense but there's
an audience for it apparently wow no
kathy griffin with the trump head
severed head um madonna's saying she
wants to blow up the white house snoop
dogg
shooting uh
kids wood chipper yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i got to see people but people yeah
people like this can make threats
towards anyone whose political views are
unpopular and that's considered
completely socially acceptable which is
kind of one of the reasons you need to
arm yourself well right so my response
now is if anyone ever says why would
anyone in this country need a gun i
would say
because a popular liberal youtuber
called for a terror attack on a on a
convention because a guy who worked for
disney called for throwing children into
a wood chipper because a comedian who
does cnn's new years showed herself a
mock uh holding up the severed head of
the president you know i can go on but
as long as they want to say stuff like
that i'm i'm i'm going to exercise my
right to keep their arms look i've been
i've been we've we've gotten death
threats we've gotten swatted eight or so
times we've had the bomb squad come out
here yeah uh
these people are not doing themselves
any justice by saying there's no reason
to have guns when they are you know
advocating for calling for violence and
then you see the george floyd riots and
then as i'll say that i'll be like well
um why would people need guns um because
in 2020 we saw the worst race riots
we've seen in the past 50 years with
over two billion dollars in in uh
tracked damage probably more damage than
that but the insurance companies only
paid up to that much you saw around 26
to 30 or so dead people from those riots
i kind of think the left has
absolutely absolutely done everything in
their power to make sure we truly
understand why we need guns well yeah
they call for insurrection and threaten
to riot every single time something
doesn't go their way but we remember
what happened also during the riots when
the police were called they were
wouldn't go into some areas you were
left to your own devices there were
business owners that thought
all i want to do is kind of guard my
storefront and i'll call the police if
there's an attack and they did so
and the police couldn't or wouldn't come
in there so
yeah that seemed to prove the plan and
then you have david doran who was
murdered trying to protect you know he
was an off a retired cop and tried to
protect his friend's pawn shop during
those riots and he was murdered you know
so
and i think what's also upsetting is the
uh the exact opposite with trump and
january 6 and in his language it was the
not even remotely anything like what
this clan guy is saying um he was saying
very normal things that politicians say
when they're upset about elections and
and uh using the same sort of language
and then he also said i think it was up
to you know at least 10 000 national
guard troops i want there and it was
nancy pelosi who turned them down so
everything is uh you know
twisted exactly the opposite you know
you know what i was thinking when i was
seeing the story about uh ethan and
hatred podcast is that he got started by
doing edgy comedy on reddit and youtube
no political background not well versed
in politics but because politics has
become pop culture he's adopted politics
so now he's getting more political
because this is what people care about i
mean the market dictates for me it's
kind of the other direction i started
with political activism working at
non-profits and then moved into media
so i think for me it's like i come from
a place where i've lived it i've
experienced it i've been reading about
it i've been actually advocating for
policy back you know when i used to do
the non-profit stuff and now here i'm in
media talking about all this and there's
a large conversation ethan klein's
podcast has comparable viewership to our
podcast and so he's got millions of
followers who watch this but they're
getting a pop culture perspective on
political issues with with limited
knowledge and very short uh relative
knowledge so you know we've had some of
these leftists on the show
they're like i was too young during job
i don't remember obama i was 12. you
know it's like 22 now i have no idea
what happened and so you know for for
many of us especially the you know
people who watch in the key demo oh we
remember what it was like under obama
under biden we remember that the killing
of the americans without charge or trial
the killing of american children the
drone strikes on civilians we remember
the corrupt dealings many people have no
idea so you'll get someone like ethan
klein i think he's like a year older
than me doing a show where all of a
sudden he's in politics it would be akin
to me one day saying we're a football
podcast now because people like football
and we're going to talk about football
yeah we'd retain viewership we'd slowly
start building up that audience but i
have no idea anything about football
well it's scary to realize as i do i'm
probably older than the oldest person in
this room
that there are people that don't
remember
10 years ago if people started watching
the news and there's obviously a whole
generation of kids
that wasn't watching news until 2016 and
post which is i think when there was one
of the biggest fastest transformations
of what we see as news with all the fake
fact checks and so on and the bias
that's all they know that's what they
think the news does the news tells you
what to think the news tells you who's
right and wrong you know gives gives
their opinion and tries to force that
down your throat and the new sensors so
that you don't think the wrong thing
yeah absolutely and just
when you look at how bold they're
getting and how
just embolden people who are on the side
of the establishment feel
to you know spew this kind of violent
rhetoric could you even imagine a
mainstream celebrity or youtube
celebrity who just began to comment on
political issues from a conservative
perspective said that people should bomb
some left-wing organization so that they
should do that like the aclu or a
planned parenthood conference or
something like that i mean first of all
it would be a story ever that everyone
was talking about but it would also be
used as an excuse to censor every single
other conservative in the sphere because
they would say well this one guy was a
radical lunatic and so that means we
need to censor everyone else who's ever
associated with them or is near them
because we're just going to get more of
this unless we really stomp down on it
quickly but he can say something as
horrific as this which is literally a
direct incitement to terrorism and it's
totally acceptable he goes well i'm
sorry i'm sorry guys and then it just
goes away i don't think he said he was
sorry at all actually wow okay fantastic
i think he said i got a little
passionate there i should walk that back
and then later came out and said it was
a joke and i'm like dude you weren't
joking and your wife agreed with you and
you said it it was only after your
producer or somebody you like he looks
over at him and then says okay okay i'll
walk that one back got a little
passionate there and then he called for
other things like firing guns into the
air which is
lethal like it's extremely dangerous
don't don't blanks also kill you if they
fall well blanks don't reject anything
well if you put a blank up to someone's
head yeah you blank
cartridge he was saying fire to the air
there's nothing that comes out it's just
a blast but i mean but you know a
crazies would hear that and then and
take it a step too far so i mean it's
incitement but it's just if anyone on
the right or any one anti-establishment
said that their channel would be removed
immediately permanently he got
permanently yeah and then and they would
get banned across the board from every
other platform yeah he's even banned
elsewhere he's been banned donald uh
facebook or instagram
no i don't know about that he's
suspended for a week can i ask you from
just youtube or anything yeah yeah just
youtube just as it was so none of the
other ones no no no just a one week
suspension alex jones said
something of yep i'm going to say you
know he said to people
to what
he said get your battle rifles ready
because blah blah blah
and he was saying that it was figurative
they didn't care they said you're gone
yeah also yeah it which is a much more
reasonable explanation right there is no
figurative version of go bomb these
people at this time yeah someone should
go bomb this group that's not
figurative that is a clear-cut literal
statement you can't fall back and it was
just a joke guys
here's another thing that they do on the
uh these leftists will say we'll call
for violence and then they'll say in
minecraft
and i'm like oh please that that doesn't
work legally but apparently it does
because they're not getting rated by the
feds they're not getting suspended they
will say things like people need to take
up their guns and go
attack this group in a video game and
then and they're like oh well we can't
ban it when when the news cycle changes
to being outraged about like a phony
insurrection they're going to get up on
their high horse about how insurrection
is horrible even though they're
constantly calling for violence there
was that mom that spoke at one of these
school board meetings where the parents
have been around the country kind of
arrayed about all the things going on i
mean the domestic terrorists yeah yeah
that's right yeah and she said something
like i'm coming here monday fully armed
if you
if you make the kids wear masks whatever
it was we're not having it anymore and
they arrested her for that and she said
she was being figurative she meant arm
to she said something that she said we
mean to unseat you right i didn't mean i
was going to come and
hurt anybody
but yeah they so they arrested her but
they didn't arrest klein because he's
calling for physical harm also on
actually called
on the governor well yeah he didn't mean
it real fast
so he was just joking do you guys
remember uh boogie he fired a gun into
the air oh yeah you guys know the story
he's a youtuber and some guys
and he pulled out a 22 and he like
raised it up and fired he got charged
for that i'm pretty sure he got arrested
and charged that's something so yeah my
point here is um
what what
he walked it back right away and said he
got a little passionate i don't know if
that's an affirmative defense for a
direct incitement to terror to be to be
honest like i don't know if you can call
for something like that on a show to
millions of people and then when walking
it back if people say they still heard
it and that still you know told them
what you thought yeah so i don't i i was
gonna do it i'm not a lawyer but i'm
wondering if when you get arrested for
terroristic threats if you said i
immediately said no
it probably mitigates it but i'm not
sure at a rate yeah i i think the
response from the d.a would be so you
confess well yeah well and also as if
some maniac in his fan base who would
commit an act of violence is going to go
oh he said he got too passionate i'm not
going to do it now right i got to be
honest though i don't really care all
that much
in the sense that
i don't expect him to face any
repercussions from this i'm surprised he
got suspended
it took like a day or two before he
actually had any adverse reaction from
youtube which was surprising
he he made multiple calls for threats of
assault or violence what people didn't
understand about assault is that
depending on your jurisdiction assault
doesn't mean physically attacking
someone it's verbal it can be verbal or
it can be an action so in illinois
assault is putting someone within reason
within reasonable fear of harm so when
he called on people to fire blanks he's
calling for people to assault the home
of the governor depending on the
jurisdictional context i'm not sure
texas has that in new york assault is
causing actual physical harm
that means that if someone grabs you but
doesn't cause any visible bruise the
cops are going to be like no assault
occurred which is which is weird so it
depends on jurisdiction but when i say i
don't care
nothing's going to happen
i mean i'm surprised it did and
this is
we know
we know they did it years ago with the
riots we know they did it in 2017 with
the riots in dc we know they get away
with it we know that uh dc actually paid
ante for millions of dollars in a
lawsuit or or have to pay
after their charges were dismissed the
anti-people filed the lawsuit and won
against the city so not only do they
continue to do this they continue to
escalate it
yeah i i accept that as a reality what
what more can you expect do you think
the suspension sort of going off a
little turn here
that you didn't expect on youtube does
that have anything to do with the elon
effect is there are there token steps
being made in some instances now because
everybody recognizes that when things
aren't fair and they're very one-sided
someone like elon could come in and do
something no he couldn't buy youtube and
the fact that h3 wasn't terminated
immediately for this shows the bias
alex jones got wiped out across the
board on every platform all around the
exact same time and it was for nebulous
reasons but if youtube hadn't suspended
this guy for a week would anybody have
raised kane other than people they don't
care about yeah well it covers them
right and it allows them to say oh no we
did take action against them of course
we suspended him the whole so so the
issue here is what he said was so far
beyond what they could ever try to
defend i mean saying someone should bomb
you know a building or whatever
was so far beyond anything they could
argue was allowed they had no choice and
all they did was give them a single
strike
but it's like they called it bullying
and harassment that's what they did they
said the video's been removed for
bullying and harassment i'm like wow
calling on millions of people incitement
to a terror attack yeah i know i know i
know he walked it back after he got
called out doesn't matter but seriously
we've not been extended at courtesy when
we had alex jones on the show he made a
comment about the death penalty and i
immediately called him out and said dude
none of that you can't say that and
youtube said we don't care and i was
like not only was it not me we said no
to it they're like so what and we got uh
we got a warning because we don't have
uh we didn't have that was our first
warning so for ethan i guess he's he's
already had his warning so now you get
one warning and then you move on a
strike so for us we didn't get taken
down yeah well i think what you said
just going back a little bit what you
said about him switching from being
entertainment into
something he should not be
dabbling in i think that that is also
just kind of generally a broader
cultural problem we have with i mean
just our education system because
you know the university system and now
the k-12 it's like
in in their view they're they're doing
the rules for radicals so for them you
know using
this type of aggression or using uh
language that is incitement for them
that that is actually normalized and
that's that's that the culture is such
that uh when it when a conservative it
doesn't even get remotely close to that
uh they can't handle it because
everything the default setting is to be
so hard left because of our education
system and culture and and hollywood and
media so that
it it's just a it's all
it's like the soup it's like the
crockpot it's it's that's what we that's
what we soak in carrie you reminded me
that a few years ago i thought it was a
joke a lot of these things that i hear
and i think is a joke and it becomes
true one of them was there were college
campus
authorities as well as students who were
saying
that if you say certain things to people
it's akin to violence
and there was actually a case where a
teacher
at a california college went to court
and argued that these anti-abortion
signs that kids were holding up on
campus were akin to
violence against her she lost the case
but i thought the claim was sort of a
joke so at the same time
some people on that side are claiming
mere
language or mere signs you know
protected free speech and language is
akin to violence by the same token when
that is committed by somebody on that
side it is then
viewed quite differently this is why i
said i don't care
because i think if you haven't realized
by now the asymmetrical cultural warfare
that's been going on
i don't know what to tell you i'm just i
don't think i can keep saying it every
time something like this happens like
there's a double standard what's
happening
that was three and a half years ago i
was talking about you know the double
standard we're saying nah that i mean i
think it was far more pronounced in the
60s basically the that's when i think
the root of a lot of this started so i
mean it goes back all the way
it it you can trace the the conflict
today all the way back
i mean literally in terms of like the
erosion of norms of just how
uh uh things that happen in the 60s in
terms of normalizing uh the breakdown of
the family normalizing the uh the hatred
of men and you know toxic masculinity
and uh weaponizing race like that that
really i think had the genesis most
powerfully in the 60s
and now here we are one of the common
themes we see with a lot of these uh
mass shootings is fatherlessness
yeah yeah family is broken one thing you
don't hear and some years ago i tried to
look into this didn't get very far but
it used to be as soon as there was a
mass shooting there was a rational
discussion or a reasonable question that
was asked as to what medicine the kids
were on because some of these
antidepressants and antipsychotic
medicines can exacerbate the feelings of
violence in some so some are apparently
helped sometimes as it says on the
warning label people become more
suicidal and more violent
all of a sudden i would say around the
2005 time period coinciding with the
pharmaceutical industry getting greater
control in my view over the media and
practically everything else that
question is no longer asked and it used
to be again that's the natural thing you
would ask not that that's the only thing
to blame but you certainly want to know
it's not even asked by the media now
like people don't say was the kid being
treated and what medicine was he on and
just like that's not a question anymore
and i yeah or did he have a father in
the home
but i would bet money that these things
are you know i would bet money that i'd
be willing to bet money the kid has been
on medication yeah for sure and i want
to say one thing before we move on
because i sense that we're about to uh
for hilah to sit there while ethan says
this and just go
i view that as a failure of being a wife
you should call your husband on his bs
right there right then especially if he
has a huge show that he's trying to make
a difference to people which i assume
ethan is trying to do but i just want to
point that out because that i see that
as a cultural feeling because it seems
like women no longer recognize that they
are supposed to be the check to their
man and be like you know what maybe you
shouldn't actually i don't think ethan
is trying to do anything i don't think
he knows about that gender of you i know
terrible i'm sorry i i when uh stephen
crowder wanted to have a conversation
with ethan klein oh yeah ethan brought
in sam cedar instead ambushing crowder
who was like okay whatever find by
ethan klein says he doesn't know
anything about politics it's his words
he's correct
but there's there's something that's
fascinating that's happened as politics
has become pop culture
i think the um
i don't know
the establishment class the uniparty the
democrats pelosi type they were so
desperate to defeat donald trump they
did everything in their power to make
politics pop culture and now they will
regret it
they you
you do not want
people who have no idea what they're
talking about to be violently angry over
these things it's like all that energy
you see when there's a baseball game
lost or won people right throughout the
city or whatever turn that into a
political issue it's gonna nah you know
you don't want that
when i was younger i used to say i wish
people cared more about politics and
then i started to understand the average
person has no interest in actually
understanding it they just want to fit
in yeah and then i'm like okay i want
the people who care about the stuff and
want to help make the world a better
place care about it i i do wish
everybody really did care about it in
the sense that they would read and
understand it what we got now is people
like ethan klein
who
has no idea what he's talking about
calls for gun control
and violence against people who have
guns and it's kind of like you're
advocating for guns
you're giving people the reason to need
them but he doesn't care i don't i you
know when i think about this idea of the
grifter in the political space
they say like so-and-so is a gift or
whatever it's like let me tell you if
someone is there is career-wise like
their whole life was politics journalism
and news and they talk about those
issues
i probably wouldn't call him a grifter
unless they did specific things like
ethan klein being a a comedy podcast
jumping into politics i'm like yo that
is definition grifting he was like hey
this edgy comedy is no longer good what
do i do let's start a podcast he
interviews jordan peterson well jordan
peterson was getting popular then uh oh
it's not popular with the left so he's
then he takes the episodes down and says
oh i shouldn't have interviewed jordan
peterson he's just doing whatever he has
to do to maintain a product for people
there you go
yeah oh no did you want to i you know
that kind of thinking that kind of
behavior it's a you know a problem with
just the total value of virtue or
breakdown of the family but also i don't
know his specific case but you look at
the way the media you know and sort of
instructs people to behave and you also
look at the way the educational system
here and i have no idea where he was
educated but speaking more broadly about
our culture as a whole i believe it was
thomas soule who made the observation
that kids in school are taught it's very
important to care about making a
difference they're not really taught
that it's very important to know all
that much about the thing you're trying
to make a difference within and it's
very interesting that that's sort of our
cultural ethos i'm going to make a
difference
okay well what kind of different you
know like just because you made
something different doesn't mean you
made it better if you didn't know what
you were doing you probably made it
worse but people aren't encouraged to do
any of the real work that it takes to
become informed about something before
commenting on it
or before
um you know trying to make some kind of
differences and activism
exactly hey that's what kids in school
should be doing but then
outside of that when people go into the
world and they say they want to be an
activist i think there's a fantastic
example of this in uh matt walsh's film
i haven't seen yet but even just in the
the preview where he asks these women at
a women's march what is a woman and they
can't give him an answer that is how can
you be at the women's march and not be
able to give an answer to the question
what does one can you imagine if you
went to like a gun rights march or
something and asked what is a gun and
the person couldn't give you a
definition it's ludicrous let me i want
to point something out this is someone i
saw this in the super chat this is uh
storm viking you mentioned this trump
spoke at the nra event yeah
ethan klein called for terror against an
event that had the former president at
it with secret service details so this
is
i mean it's crazy this is the state
we're in it's okay because it was
against trump but i'm gonna say though
i'm gonna so guys get ready to drink
cause i'm gonna say those two magic
words civil war snap
here's here's here's what i see
um
i think most people who've watched the
show probably heard me make this point
but again i i some people are like i've
heard this before tim not everybody's
heard it boomers are mostly unified in
their politics there's little division
among boomers they do have their wedge
issues gen xers are similar but
millennials are so divided that you can
have someone like ethan klein call for
active terror
like how does that even happen like i
can't imagine growing up someone
accidentally calling for a terror attack
against a former an event with the
former president speaking at i mean that
sounds
absurd to me but at the point now where
let's just say
he got too passionate that's what he
said and it slipped out
what's the next generation going to be
like if ethan has no reason to try to to
apologize for this
and he he basically didn't he just said
i got a little passionate and then he
said republicans of the party have dead
children further inflaming tribal
tensions instead of just saying yeah i
should not have said that i'm so sorry
guys we got to tone things down no he
actually escalated the rhetoric against
republicans
if that's the direction things are going
you take a look at how the parallel
economies have emerged there's something
that i worried about several years ago
2018 i said
if we keep seeing censorship i talked
about this with jack dorsey you will you
will force people to to create a
parallel economy if they are to function
banning people and taking away their
livelihood will not stop them from
living it will force them to find
alternate alternate means of trade
eventually you will see a larger and
larger parallel economy separate from
yours
once that happens people will have no
reason whatsoever to accommodate the
other
ethan klein is a perfect example he can
call for this and the only reason in my
opinion he walked it back is because he
knew you two he knew youtube would check
out his income
but as now
we have seen twitter and many other
platforms be totally lacks and not
enforce the rules we're lucky they did
in this instance
what happens is
you'll get someone actually uh what was
it facebook allowed people to call for
violence against russians
there was um what what platform had the
policy where you were allowed to rag on
white people
which one was that one i don't remember
all of them yeah was it twitch i don't
know one of them said uh you you can't
you can't um insult historically
marginalized groups but you can
you know don't remember against you know
uh historically oppressive groups or
whatever which is basically like you can
regard white people when you get to the
point where you're very monolithic there
are many
white people who are oppressed like for
sure yes yeah but yeah who cares yeah uh
slavic people are considered people of
color by the coalition of communities of
color the point is though when you get
to a point where a platform says it's
okay to target this group of people but
not this one
because they don't care to lose we're
not going to make any money from that
group anyway and we don't want to lose
money if we ban these people
you're going to get people being raised
in two different ecosystems two
different economies one kid's going to
grow up and like those people are crazy
bad people that's my parents said and
it's true
and then within a generation or two
people fight
we have that many we've all probably
talked to
young people maybe not so young people
where something that's all the rage and
discussion on one side of the spectrum
they haven't even heard anything about
you're like you don't even know about
that video or you don't even know about
something that is so big on the other
maybe parallel
i feel like though that it's more on the
other direction like i feel like
uh like when trump won like
like just the conservative ecosystem
like i was at an event with jack dorsey
he did not know who william f buckley
was you know a billionaire founder of
it's like how
like the familiarity with like the
intellectual underpinnings of
conservatism they would have no clue but
i think most of us here at the table are
just people watching the show like could
very well you know explain who the the
leftist you know leaders and
publications and so that that level of
ignorance i think it's very uh
self-secluding by the left so i think
that's part of why they had such a rude
awakening with trump
yeah it shattered their worldview it was
they were told by the media it couldn't
happen
they said hillary clinton had a 99
chance of winning and then the media was
wrong
so what do you do when you're when your
world shatters like that now you lose
your mind
let's jump to this next story we'll
start talking about families we have
this from the post-millennial paramount
plus sponsors drag event where child
dances on stage for money
ladies and gentlemen um
just pull up the wikipedia entry for
stripper
and i can't do it here because it does
have nude women in the wikipedia
but uh
what you need to understand is that
stripping does not mean being nude right
some strippers can't take their clothes
off but they're still considered
strippers they call them bikini bars the
wikipedia entry actually shows it says
bikini and gogo dancing and it says the
women have to be fully clothed they have
to cover their tops and bottoms
they dance on stage and people give them
money at this event
it was a
rupaul rupaul's drag kong they had two
children on stage and this little boy
was jumping and dancing around and
taking money from people
this is grooming
this kid what they do is they put this
kid in an environment and they say it's
innocent there's nothing sexual about it
the kid then gets uh he they normalize
the behavior of dancing on stage for
money from the audience
the way grooming would work i'm not
saying they will do to this kid but the
way it would work is that after you do
this
when the kid is a little older you then
say hey it's going to be a swim a
swimsuit show we're doing a take your
shirt off
then
they give you money then oh we're going
to do we're going to do another swimsuit
thing but this one you got you have to
wear these special swimsuits and then
they give them speedos or something
that's how grooming works they it works
on adults
there are people who are groomed into
being uh sex workers
through this this is not the most
egregious thing we've seen there was
desmond is amazing who quite literally
removed clothing on stage
and then took money from people
at a bar full of adults
they're grooming your kids
paramount is sponsoring this discovery
plus is a child drag event
this is
this is a reality
it's almost like there's a lot of
pedophiles in media or something like
that weird yeah well they normalize it
one step at a time and so here's the
goal they want you to look at this and
say well it's just people dancing you
know is it really that that's what
they'll say to you they'll say it's just
dancing right right they have to it's a
drag show it's a bunch of pervy dudes
dressing up like dressing up and trying
to act like they're female dancers
and it's not innocent so what they'll do
is they'll say it's just like a costume
show what are you so mad about why are
you so obsessed i wonder why you care so
much sheamus yeah yeah well that's the
thing right like let's expose children
to this because we care so much that it
has to be forced onto young ones and
then when you point out that there's
something wrong with that you're the one
putting inordinate attention on it
so
the family's been destroyed
there is a uh you know when i was
covering this in my my uh my tim cast
channel segment there was a photo of
drag queen story hour where there's
these liberal parents smiling and
laughing as they put their kids in front
of this
they're into it
they like it i think it says something
about where the
parents are coming from of course and i
hope this was a parody account but it
reminds me of on twitter a couple of
years ago there's a woman
didn't say was a parody account who was
complaining at being attacked because
she had in her bio that she was
transgendering her
twin toddlers
i didn't even know what that meant i had
to think about it it just you know
build more i think it's a big reason why
um
in virginia where i live that's why
you know we had glenn young can win i
was a volunteer on his campaign and a
lot of it had to do with the schools and
what was being taught in schools and a
lot of this gender ideology which should
not be taught in schools it should be
something if you as a parent you have
the right to teach your children
your values and terry mcauliffe the
democrat opponent said no that uh they
shouldn't be telling teachers what to
think so i think i mean having worked on
the campaign i was there on election
night it gave me a lot of hope that
there are a lot of parents who are
pushing back on this so homeschool your
kids yeah there's no question about it
at this point home school yeah or
private christian schools or even then
you really have to vet it that's true
too really
they have the christian schools have
some of the same accreditation
facilities that require them to do this
things you'd be surprised that the
public schools have to do
but there is a trend as you guys know
and destroying this in full measure
recently toward not just homeschooling
but there's pods now there's groups
there's organizations in the
neighborhood where they're getting
actual more formal group education just
outside the public school system
that parallel economy is forming people
are just deciding
they don't agree with it and if you keep
going too radical in the school system a
parallel
system is going to develop i think we're
there with the schools it's interesting
because with the entire public school
structure which you know has been
imitated by a lot of these private
schools as well the way the system has
been set up we take it for granted but
it really is very bizarre that the
status quo is such that
parents send their children
to go off with complete strangers for
basically the entire day for basically
their entire childhood that is very
strange and to learn not just stuff we
consider traditional education but all
of their social values and their moral
values and all the extra stuff that as a
parent you kind of want to do yourself
usually
yeah well i think unfortunately a lot of
parents don't i think unfortunately a
lot of parents don't want to do it
themselves it's very sad but i think it
happens a lot they don't want to have
uncomfortable conversations there are
people who even say sex ed needs to be
taught in schools why well because i
don't have have that conversation with
my kid what's wrong with you you want a
stranger too they were raised in that
system as well yeah that's also true
that's fair it's fair point yeah who was
who was it who was talking about how
kids who agrees to grow up on a farm
knew about the birds and the bees
because yes the animals yeah i've
mentioned that before well when i was in
high school another student literally
asked me the question
how did people learn about sex before
sex ed i'm not kidding wow like are you
i was like well because
people were a more closely connected to
nature b people figure out how to do
that on their own the reason you have
sex education the reason adults need to
talk to young people about that kind of
thing is to tell them what not to do
that's the whole point you're getting
older um
and
x y and z
and this you should know that yes you
should be married to someone before you
do x y and z this makes children well
seamus uh i think you got to be fair to
these people you see uh before the
advent of sex ed humans had no idea how
to reproduce yeah that's true
we didn't know what was coming we're
very lucky
we were very much like panda bears yeah
we were not smart aliens came and and
taught us
about reproduction and then we wrote it
down in books and now we have to teach
kids otherwise who knows what will
happen well the other thing was that we
didn't know that men could get pregnant
and that's something that we're only
just now learning and uh but i do have
to do a plug for the the bill that um we
talked about a little bit earlier and if
if you all watching can go to women's
bill of rights.com we are pushing back
on this at the federal level and also at
the state level so we just introduced a
week and a half ago a bill the women's
bill of rights
and it says
it's a resolution to codify that a woman
is a woman and we define what a woman is
their biological sex that she has a
uterus uh that she has you know female
reproductive organs it's really pathetic
that we have to spell this out but we're
doing it and so we've had several
members of congress uh including a
democrat katie porter from pennsylvania
so kudos to her
we're working also with the women's
liberation front which is a hard left
feminist group
and as a conservative group we want to
work with women who want to protect
women's rights and then we're also going
to be moving it for the next phase to
the state level as well so you can
contact your local legislature and say
we want this and i want it in my state
too we're doing at the federal level and
the state level so how do you define
woman
well on the website we have it here it's
uh i can read it for purposes of state
federal law a person's sex is defined as
his or her biological sex either male or
female at birth
or purposes of statement of law
yes a female is an individual whose
biological reproductive system is
developed to produce ova a male is an
individual whose biological reproductive
system is developed to fertilize the ova
of a female for purposes of a state
federal law woman and girl refer to
human females and the term man and boy
refer to human males so simple well
there you go actually things a little
complicated you know
because when you're mentioning you know
uterus and overall stuff i'm like you
could build one of those in the future
right take an animal's uterus and put it
in a the argument that they make is what
about a woman who has had a hysterectomy
now she's not a woman anymore it's like
very bad argument yeah but but it it
works on weak-minded people yeah that's
why it's like adult human female and a
dull human male and they're like well
what's a male or what's a female oh you
want to read the biology of it all okay
now x
x y
yeah but even that and even that goes so
much deeper right because it's not as if
we discovered the the x-axis and x-y
chromosomes and went oh my gosh there's
two categories of people that we now
know about it's just been it's obvious
from the get-go it's insane that we
haven't explained people now i think i
think i don't know if you made this
point last week was a really good point
humans didn't discover the xyx and x and
y chromosome until recently yeah but
humans always knew they were exactly
kinds of people it wasn't created as a
social construct for the purpose of you
know make oppressing people this is
something i assumed since the beginning
of time although i wasn't there
that has been recognized and accepted
you know without being controversial
until really relatively recently i
wouldn't be surprised if we already are
already are starting to see the argument
where they say that the x and y
chromosomes aren't real and that they
were created to reinforce the
patriarchal gender binary
they will literally say science is
sexist yeah that's right i say it was a
bunch of white men that's it who needed
a legal way to you know uh what was
called phrenology yeah with the head
measurement yeah they would measure the
heads yeah
like they wanted to justify racist ideas
so uh chromosomes
not a real thing as it turns out well
and this is because they do not use
language the way human beings are
supposed to use language they're not
trying to comp they're not trying to
communicate any kind of truth right so
when they talk about what a woman is
what insurrection is what terrorism is
what violence is they get it wrong
constantly right they call men women
they call statements of fact about what
a person's biology is violence they call
it terror they don't call it terrorism
to tell someone that they should bomb a
public event that the former president
of the united states is going to be at
oh no it was a jew well he did get
really passionate and he walked it back
so i guess we're fine with it but they
they literally use it to try to signal
what they want it's very sad and it's
unbecoming it's degrading it's not how
humans are supposed to use language
that's actually kind of the way that
like dogs use language when you tell
your dog sit give me paw he doesn't
understand those words he knows he'll
get a treat and that's what we have
actual grown adult human beings walking
around doing using words and only
understanding them in the context that
gets them what they want instead of the
truth that's actually supposed to lie
beneath the phrasing so let's let's
let's dissect that a little bit what
you're saying is
the dog basically hears rumple and then
when he knows to respond to that sound
he'll get a treat but he doesn't
understand the concepts or ideas behind
what it means exactly so my dog does
yeah sure well yours is special your dog
is very special you have a colleague
right the collie is the smartest breed i
think there you go yep i think i think i
don't i don't know if i agree with the
dog analogy thing i think it's fair to
say
you don't you don't need to use it you
say there are people who don't
understand what they're saying yeah they
just know that they can say certain
words and they'll be rewarded well
that's my point
we had a progressive on the show who
said conservatives are saying trans
people don't exist what and i said what
does that mean what and he was like huh
i'm like what does that mean like ben
shapiro knows blair white he knows she
exists what does that mean
they don't they don't think trans people
exist i'm like okay you're not telling
me anything and that's your point
exactly the specific phrase to get their
point across to get what they want from
you to shame you instead of
communicating an actual idea that's like
transphobic as we've talked about um may
as well be a grunt exactly people call
transphobic often what the person
calling them that means is you don't
like the idea of
trans people but they're not afraid of
trans people they are not transphobic
i'm not sure how that word has become
just accepted into the lexical same
thing as homophobic yeah yeah yeah
you're scared of gay people not really
well it's interesting you made this
point that it could just be a grunt it's
really like any word could be a grunt we
we make noises
and those noises are understood to have
certain meanings but what a human is
supposed to be able to do is is abstract
with those noises understand what they
mean use them honestly my point with the
dog analogy is whenever humans fail to
live up to their rational potential they
behave animalistically
you know i think um
words
are oppressive
uh english is a colonial language and if
we want to truly speak in a way that is
representative of all human cultures
clicks and whistles grunts yeah
yeah well that's honest and to be fair
when women aren't around that is how men
talk yeah yeah that's true
yeah if you watch the um the sheamus
freedom tunes members only
you know we'll i'll i'll read the line
as dr fatchi like you have to wear your
mask and then i'll look up your chain
and go oh
i have the antidote uh to your word
question and it's called the worktionary
oh so we made this product with the
independent women's network so you go to
iwnetwork.com
i'll give you this after the show you're
ready to have it yes it defines all
these terms like white adjacent systemic
racism triggered uh restorative justice
implicit bias it's all here we spell it
out the real english we give the real
definition of your point i've asked
people in my orbit because i had to look
this up everybody's starting
years ago started saying equity equity
equity instead of equality i'm like but
no one explained that when journalists
adopt these phrases of advocacy i think
they better know what they're i think
they probably shouldn't usually because
it more thought should go into it you
can quote somebody but you shouldn't be
adopting it and i looked up equity and
it's as you guys probably know but i
think a lot of ordinary folks we don't
totally different than equality and if
you ask young people using that phrase
and it's just you know ubiquitous today
most people can't define equity versus
equality exactly because they don't need
to you say the word you get the treat
well it's equal outcomes versus equal
opportunity that's equity is socialism
equality is equality of opportunity
meritocracy exactly they do not like
meritocracy at all no
equity to me is the notion of you
pre-define people based on
your understanding without knowing
somebody of what their skill set is or
what their abilities are and you tell
them
based on something like skin color
that they can't do something as well as
everybody else and they need help i mean
that's that's how i describe equity
where there are other people who don't
and that you're telling to me it's
almost the opposite of what the goal is
because you're labeling a certain group
of people based on nothing but well if
you if you look at the arguments they
make it's
one group has privileges and so they
should be held back other groups have
disadvantages so they should be pushed
forward yeah so equity is hobble those
who are successful it's kind of a tall
grass it's it's it's typical communist
ideology yeah exactly and in is a kid in
america who in my generation we were all
told whatever color we were this was our
thing as you can be anything and we
that's what we thought i hear women
today talking about
you know i want my daughter to know that
you know women could even be doctors i'm
like we knew that in the 1960s like who
told you
in 1990 or 2000 that that wasn't
possible because we've been through all
there
i really don't think they think about
they're living in an insane fantasy land
they have a persecution complex
everything's the handmaid's tell right
there was some comment that someone
posted where it says this little black
girl is in school and she's asked what
she wants to be when she goes up or
something she says i want to be an
astronaut the teacher goes that's great
and she goes what the teachers are like
that's that's fantastic and the girl
says no you're supposed to tell me i
can't do it cause i'm a woman and she
was like but you can do it it doesn't
matter and then she was like you know
this famous astronaut that i'm a big fan
of was told she couldn't do it so she
you know fought against it and rose to
be the best and she was like yes and
because of her you now
can do it no one's holding you back and
then it just shows like the panel the
girl like shocked and confused but it's
but it's fascinating because i've
experienced this
that in the modern era these activists
actually tell people
you can't succeed that's what i'm saying
because of your race right so don't try
it's their fault
who did it wouldn't have occurred to
them because that wasn't the case and
they're suddenly identified at a fairly
early age now i'm told that you are
different and you can't do things you
know that yeah that's what our winsome
sears our lieutenant governor of
virginia who was junkin's running mate
she said that's what crt does it makes
the the light in the child's eyes you
know if you tell you know and she she's
black herself and she said if you tell
black children
you can't succeed you're inherently uh
flawed
why why would we even think they would
try right of course they're gonna fall
you know into gangs and drugs because we
keep telling them that they're victims
and that they're hopeless
well i said it before but is it
surprising to anybody that the group of
people advocating for less population
are
favoring policies that result in
destroyed families destroyed economies
sterilization of children and outright
abortion of children the planned
parenthood thing i thought was a
conspiracy theory for years you know and
now they're having to grapple with it
which
which one which part of it yeah
what's what's
yes
by the way i'm a very late comer to
politics so i'm one of the people you
guys are talking about sometimes but but
you were journalists margaret sanger
you know was part of wanting to
apparently shape and annihilate you know
black population and now planned
parenthood is having to grapple with
that and on their website they address
this you know the fact that that was the
case and how they feel about that now
and you know that's a very tough thing
for them but oh i i read it was a fact
check i think it was uh which one one of
those fact checkers maybe it was the
washington post we were just talking i
was just gonna bring that up saying
about the kkk rally because someone said
oh margaret singer spoke at kkk rallies
and so they did fact check about whether
that was true and they said no um
actually she only spoke at one event one
kkk event and it was a women's kkk event
it was like like the women who were
attached to the men in the kkk so it was
like a women's kkk event okay and and
she had she had a pure intention for
going there she was just trying to
spread her message of birth control to
whoever would listen so so they they
literally said it was okay that she went
to a kkk event because she was trying to
teach about birth control to everybody
no matter who would listen so she uh i
was just like
do you hear what you're saying
insane i gotta address uh you know
michael malus who's a big friend of the
show and a good friend of mine
he's he's argued this is not true about
margaret sanger and you know recently
was talking to him and he was like no no
this is not true she was advocating for
birth control she was trying to end
poverty by telling these women and i'm
just like
i hear your argument dude
but i pulled up plannedparenthood.org
that outright calls her racist she's a
eugenicist she wants you gentlemen
she's bloated planned parenthood calls
her racist yep she's actually i don't i
i i suppose it's you know i think
michael's a very smart guy and and i
respect him a whole lot but i don't
understand how
his point can be correct that she wasn't
maybe i got something wrong in in what
he was saying but they actually say she
believed in an inherently racist and
ableist ideology that labeled certain
people on unfit to have children she
believed in eugenics we denounced her
her beliefs in eugenics she she was
going to the black community
specifically telling them to stop having
kids
it sounds like she was racist you know i
don't know whatever a lot of everybody
was racist back then to to varying
degrees right they were raised against
irish people right yeah but and what's
so bizarre is that there's such a total
disconnect between
that fact and then the outcome of the
disparity of the proportion of black
children who are then killed you know i
think the ratio is like four or five uh
you know five to one black to white
babies but but yet black people are a
much smaller per percentage of the
population so her vision has been
realized like she got what she was
dreaming for i was and that's what's
disgusting it's like planned parenthood
doesn't acknowledge this i was watching
a video from it was actually some like
critical race theorist guy who pointed
this out it was like a black
identitarian guy saying
margaret sanger was racist planned
parenthood says she's racist and he uh
they were explaining how
uh
if the black population
wasn't getting abortion at the rate they
were there would be a substantially
larger portion of the u.s population by
now
but you were mentioning it's like five
to one oh yeah yeah they were they were
um the the second largest minority group
ahead of latinos but because of abortion
black people are more likely to abort
than latinos now latinos have suppressed
uh surpassed black americans as the
biggest uh second biggest group
what was the was that was that the
conspiracy theory you're talking about
are you talking about selling baby parts
or something absolutely well
that's great i found out about margaret
sanger because um an african-american
girlfriend and my brother some years ago
referred to
referred to it and it surprised me
because i had always just heard it in
passing and didn't put any thought into
that being possibly true but she said oh
black people know this and i i yeah so i
looked it up and
yeah yeah we had um daryl davis on and
he's gone relatively woke he used to
talk to members of the kkk and talk them
out of that ideology and he said that
his mother knew even then like a long
time ago she knew that they were like
trying to use black people that for
example we all know about you know the
tuskegee
experiments and stuff like that he said
that they understood that planned
parenthood was kind of a little bit of
an extension of that i'm paraphrasing
him i don't misquote him but my
understanding was that they knew that
that's what planned parenthood was going
for which was like really eye-opening
for me i was like they knew it was very
much common knowledge and it was just
one of those things they just accepted
it no but not only do they accept it
they promote it like they say
uh you know these white supremacists who
are pro-life they want to hold back
black women you know that's a it's a
moral good for black women to want to
abort their children yeah and uh and
good on senator tim scott because he
called out janet yellen you know janet
yellen said uh you know if we had you
know fewer abortions in the past then
that we would have had a much smaller
gdp growth and tim scott said you know
as the as the you know black uh son of a
single mother i am so glad that she did
not share your view basically so i just
want to issue a clarification according
to planned parenthood they're not
selling tissue they're donating it
oh that's nice yeah so what about that
project
for money but nobody didn't project
veritas
videos about this
i also asked people to look up because
you can find not the story but the the
press announcement abc a couple of years
ago with one of my former producers kim
skeen and chris wallace who worked at
abc at the time because kim kim turned
me on to this
back when you could cover normal stories
that people cared about in a normal way
as a journalist without getting canceled
they did a story on the
sale of body parts you know by fetal
body parts and the market among the
pharmaceutical industry and others for
clinical study and all kinds of things
and
again that story is nowhere to be found
on the internet but if you google
or duck.go your choice whatever i mean
i mean
abc's 2022 air report on fetal tissue
trafficking read a little bit of that
read about how much they were paying for
i think um a brain
there was literally a quote from one of
the directors of planned parenthood
saying she wanted to buy a new car
unbelievable so i don't care if they see
me i do not believe it today it's
project verides what i'm telling you is
not long ago abc news
and chris wallace were doing this kind
of reporting when reporters were you
know more open to doing neutral stories
on important controversies and so so the
organization i don't believe it was um i
don't believe it was uh oh man i'm
blanking on the name veritas it was the
center for medical progress and what
they did is after they filmed
uh these
these employees of planned parenthood
and representatives haggling over the
price of fetal tissue they edited it yes
but they placed the full unedited
footage on the internet for anyone to
watch if they wanted to and they got in
trouble right like everything on the
news is edited at some point if it's not
just a full raw hour-long tape so well
and the reason if i understand probably
that david deliden actually got in
trouble was just because of uh two-party
consent laws with respect to filming
people it wasn't because he edited
anything deceptively or dishonestly
right
that was an argument yeah of course that
used to not be an argument and i saw
that raised when i was doing at cbs not
about me but when people wanted to make
controversies all of a sudden
opposing people politically would say
that tape was edited i'm like yeah all
of our tapes are edited everything and
people who are deceptively editing a
tape do not place the entirety of the
footage online for everyone to be able
to watch it
so this was a big story in 2015.
undercover video shows planned
parenthood official discussing fetal
organs used for research
they responded to it saying it's tissue
donation
but in the video she and so in the the
footage
the uh the woman literally says
they're just whoever grows out yes she
says whoever throws out a figure in a
negotiation first loses
now that you know the thing you say when
you're donating something to somebody
insanity
but what is donation right they don't
know what words mean or they don't use
them properly they are intentionally
accepted you know what does donation
mean you say you're paying for
time and transportation of the stuff and
to have it preserved so that there's all
kinds of ways to say you're not paying
for the tissue but in fact sheamus i'm
going to donate this uh loctionary to
you thank you so much hey can you spot
me 20 bucks yeah of course man you got
to make a profit off your donations
that's right no no
he didn't you got to pay for the lights
and then you were sitting here yeah yeah
he didn't sell me anything i just had
the effort you had to use to hand him by
the way
carpal tunnel risk i really i really
wish the uh the planned parenthood
defense would catch on with the irs like
no that was not that wasn't work i
didn't sell that that was not i donated
that but i mean i happened to make money
but it was something tells me that the
the irs isn't going to be
concerned about that
federal agencies are not going to go
after the left in this way ever ever
look at what happened with donald trump
and russia gate
one of the one of the biggest con i mean
not now we're looking at the suspend
trial with all with with what's going on
hillary clinton knowing about and
signing off on a lot of the stuff some
of the most shocking revelations we've
heard in a long time russia gate was
staged it was fake it was a hoax
tricking the government the many
elements of the government the fbi knew
it was fake they went after it anyway
wow it was gonna be like how many that
were really tricked so we got a couple
guys which was part of his defense
actually the assessment that was his
defense i was like well they already
knew so i wasn't actually
it was immaterial if i was lying well in
the fbi's defense is we didn't know that
they're such bad at their job so they're
supposed to be top federal agents that
they don't even do due diligence when a
political operative brings them research
on one of the most sensitive things they
could do which is someone an opposing
political campaign
my sources at fbi tell me they used to
not go you know within
a mile of an investigation like that it
was so controversial just to avoid any
appearance of conflict they stayed away
from journalists and political figures
at least the honest guys and now we're
to believe that they didn't even do due
diligence when they're handed you know
opposition research well it was because
he they he knew him personally because
sustainment had worked formally at the
fbi and even so they should have
questioned the guy who met with james
baker was my former professor at uh
harvard law school uh actually a good
person like and he and he's the one who
i think is uh at the center of the
damning text messages that he's reported
so good on him so uh wow yeah
was well do we know if he lied or if he
just got passionate in the moment and
then walked it back it was a passionate
text message
they're walking
can't wait for them to apologize saying
double standard dave smith at this point
it's like nails on a chalkboard because
he's like yes yes we know we know it's
it's not it's
it's you know some 16 year old is going
to start watching the news and then go
to his dad and be like dad there's a
double standard he's going to go
ah son i remember when i thought that
was going to be the case yeah i think
it's uh dave smith and uh robbie
bernstein always make this joke like oh
no we're waiting for an apology on that
it's going to come any day they're going
to apologize any day any day i'm sure
i'm sure carter page last time i checked
the former trump campaign associate who
was improperly spied upon with doctored
evidence from the fbi who by the way had
never met or talked to or communicated
with donald trump directly but through a
wiretap improperly done on carter page
donald trump's communications could be
captured the way they allow themselves
to capture
all the communications of those in orbit
around the one wiretap person to this
day as far as i know he has not received
so much as an apology in fact
his efforts at his own expense to try to
get some
let's say equity in court over all that
happened to him have just gone
unanswered his case has been thrown out
the fbi has not said so much as you know
now that we've convicted the one lawyer
if nothing else of doctoring a document
in your case we're sorry nothing you
know just standing oh he only got
probation he got like i think like 400
hours of community service although he
should have spent a year in jail trump
needs to win in 2024
we had cash patel on the show
and my attitude is just fire everybody
as soon as trump wins again just get in
there and just fire everyone um
you're fired the the line he's famous
for he's just
well and the press strategy should be
different too so i was there uh working
for john solomon who's hopefully going
to come on with you guys soon uh with
just the news and that was the year in
2020 when we were launching so it was
the last year the trump presidency and
it was so hard to get in the room
credentialing so i was covering the
white house for him and because the
pandemic the uh white house
correspondents association was very
dictatorial about first of all they're
that way normally about who's allowed in
the room but because of covet they
severely constrained who was in the room
so as a startup working for a guy who
was you know reporting the truth john
solomon during pandemic
it was really hard to get in the room
and i only got in the room because of
kayleigh mcinerney
allowed me in the room myself and one
american news and from
one american news chanel rion their
founder
she she opened my eyes to what's
happening in that press briefing room
and our understanding is that if trump's
comes back he's going to change the
strategy of what happens in that press
briefing room because right now the wha
is a private non-profit that's a white
house correspondents exactly yeah so
alex jones press secretary
well yeah but as far as allowing yes she
said yes
no no no it was more it was more the
other way around as far as like who's
who is in the room to ask the president
a question because right now the wha is
a liberal good old boys club that's been
around for 100 years that is dictating
to the to the president who's allowed on
government property and they don't allow
conservatives in the room and if you're
a conservative and you try to get a seat
on the board for wha you can't so chanel
rion from one american news started her
own uh competing nonprofit and uh the
trump white house we you know was
considering recognizing that and getting
more equal representation in the room
because if you see the questions that
they were asking trump they were not
fair questions right like my first
question that i asked trump when i was
in in the white house press briefing
room was i asked him a question about
what was happening with hong kong and it
was uh you know jimmy lai had just been
arrested so i'm asking about china and
hong kong chanel asked a question about
iran policy in the middle east
and then i think it was somebody from
mbc asking a question about qnon so it's
like the supposed you know conspiracy
right-wing journalists are asking
stepson or policy questions and then you
have these other you know white house
correspondents association establishment
types they're there to make trump look
bad and he was he was he was
uh you know egged on because he thought
that it would win him points and at one
point with the base but i think it
turned off the suburban women the more
middle you know middle-of-the-road
people and so from what i understand
that would be one thing that he would
change uh substantially and i think it's
good i i made a couple posts on
instagram for this called the cnn
challenge and it was
that i mean there's no real challenge it
was turn on fox news
and then
whatever the news is
switch to cnn and they'll be talking
about trump
so
i used to i used to have cnn playing in
the background all the time
because you know my my mentality was
when news breaks
they'll report it really really quickly
and then one day i was just sitting in
you know i was like recording something
and then i turned the volume back up and
then i'm thinking i'm watching and i'm
just like have they been talking about
trump all day
like there was a there was like a storm
or something happened i'm like so i
changed the channel and it was like
riots in iran
and then i was like wow
all right so i'm on fox news now i
normally don't watch fox news and then
uh something else was happening i think
it was a a hurricane was coming
and i turned on cnn and they're like
doing a round table about donald trump
and then i was just like this is crazy i
switched to fox news and they're like
here's what you do expect the upcoming
storm and i was like
i guess i'll leave fox on
listen it's in cbs
when fox news started
les moonves who was head of cbs at the
time corporate came into the washington
dc newsroom and convened us all around
the conference table and said
is what's happening with fox this early
popularity is it real or is it something
that just crazy people are watching
and i was too young you know i too young
to speak up and finally understood that
that's the wrong thing to do sometimes
because i used to speak up too much in
bad situ in situations where i shouldn't
i kept my mouth shut because i was
fairly new
around the table every other journalist
there said it's just a fake stupid thing
that create that's speaking to crazies
meantime i had discovered what you had
as a former cnn person i used to have
cnn on in my you know office all day
just to see if there was breaking news
and there used to be
and when fox came on fox had news before
the other networks did and before cnn
did often sometimes a couple of days
before and the others would follow it up
so i started
being sort of the contrarian that i am
putting fox news on in my office and of
course that gets me pegged i'm sure
around the newsroom instead of
gee she's smart because we're all
watching one thing but we're all
supposed to be kind of gathering
you know breaking news and at least one
person's watching another network and
learning new things
i'm sure i was pegged as sort of that
crazy fox watcher but i saw the same
thing you did tim yep
and then i just stopped watching
well a lot of people stopped watching
cnn well now they're saying with the new
ownership they're going to purge all of
that stuff out of cnn
that that's that's just the death knell
well
also you can't it's too this is my my
opinion my thought and i interviewed a
lot of current and former cnn's for the
last book that i wrote about all of this
it's too endemic you can try it's sort
of like trump trying to get rid of the
establishment you know bureaucracy
that's the deep state you might say
you can try all you want but they're
really entrenched and strong and the
news industry whether it's not that
everybody feels the same way but so many
people in the news industry and the way
they're being brought up in journalism
colleges
um i i don't i think that's a tough road
to hoe at cnn
i think
did i say i think
i think freedom i'm triggered
meritocracy
and honesty are winning
i think you look at uh
the the
the collapse of the establishment press
you look at the expansion of gun rights
the narrative isn't working
their lies are not working
a regular person will hear we need
background checks and a ban on assault
weapons
but now they can google it and the ones
who do go hey wait a minute we already
have background checks
oh but it's a gun show loophole really
what's that google oh there isn't one
that's a lie it's a political term not a
real thing oh that's weird well what
about assault weapons
assad's having a definition wikipedia
says assault weapon is ill-defined it
typically refers to a pistol grip or
forward accessories or maybe magazine
size but there's no real definition so
when regular people are they hear these
things from joe biden
joe biden i got to tell you is red pill
and people like crazy when he's like
nine millimeters are gonna blow a lung
out of the body
you're gonna get some regular persons
who'd be like whoa really i was watching
a movie they that what and they're gonna
google and go what
that's not real what else isn't real
if joe biden was wrong about that what
else was he wrong about i think you're
right
when you overplay your hands i think the
organized campaign of propagandists to
try to create this artificial reality to
make fringe things seem as though they
are the norm to make the majority of
people think that they are in the
minority you know this is what social
media and the internet's been all about
people get wise and the truth takes a
little longer to be told but the truth
usually survives it just takes more time
yeah well
part of it is yes the language like
that's why we made the worktionaries
because the language it's news concepts
it's new things that people aren't as
familiar and then once they understand
it they're like they reject it the body
rejects that organ transplant that so
and a new one right now is the esg you
know if you say if you ask a random
person on the street what do you think
about esg you know equity social
governance for investing you know
they're not going to know what that
means but then if you explain what it
means which is uh let's uh use
capitalism and something that should be
apolitical to bludgeon and uh push in a
socialist leftist agenda
they're going to say that's not okay
it should be apolitical but but they
don't know the the lingo yet but they're
waking up and that's why you have people
you know creating strive capital uh you
know the guy who wrote woke inc is is
starting um
what you got to do
is when you go to people
talk about how esg is good
esg is it's so you want to invest and
i'm not mean this literally no financial
advice you say
you really got to take a look at this
esg stuff the idea is simple
instead of merit you know skill
determining whether or not a business
succeeds we are going to focus on
political activism
so like if if a company is going to sell
solar panels instead of hiring engineers
who have graduated with degrees we're
going to hire activists
that's going to make you a good buck
and then people are going to be like
what
how is my solar panel company going to
make money if they're doing political
activities and not selling solar panels
it reminds me of iron man when in the in
the first one he says oh marvel
reference
he uh tony stark announces they're not
doing weapons anymore and then they have
that scene of jim cramer saying the
stock and then he hits the baseball mug
with a baseball bat and says this is a
weapons company that doesn't sell
weapons
that's what esg is right you're
investing i just got to say i'm not
going to tell anybody who to invest in
my understanding is that the esg
companies did really really poorly like
in terms of you know um return that's a
shock yeah i don't know i'm just if if
you want to invest in you know a meat
processing plant that cares more about
political activism than processing meat
all right yes you gotta i i say i think
that's one of the stupidest possible
investments a single human being can
make you might as well just literally
donate the money to a charity at least
then you can write it off wait hold on
you don't think that i should invest in
the vegan run meat processing plant no
that actually i think it's a good idea
no if there is a
vegan
vegan run meat processing well i i i
should walk the back what i what i mean
say is
vegan meat plant i thought you were
saying mm-hmm i thought you're saying
that's another plant that grows meat no
but i mean like i thought that's what
you're saying yeah i thought you were
saying a plant that makes fake meat i'm
like that's a good idea actually
look i mean if that were possible yes
absolutely invest in that i'm sorry i
didn't mean to give you guys bad
financial advice it wasn't financial
advice as we like to say on the show
well there's a real-time example of that
just happened uh once you explain it to
the average you know to shareholders so
carl icahn is this hedge fund
billionaire and he's obsessed with the
treatment of pregnant pigs and he was
trying to force mcdonald's to change
their practices to meet his standards
not the industry but breast pac uh best
practice standards he said it wasn't
good enough and so he tried to force his
people to be on the board of mcdonald's
but thank god mcdonald's just uh
rejected it the shareholders and and
they vote and they said no keep keep
your activists off our board they have
no clue what they're talking about with
actual meat processing not to mention
you know low uh low income people a lot
of people average people shop at
mcdonald's this is going to make food
more expensive for them so you have a
hedge fund billionaire trying to make
food way more expensive for average
people and they rejected it i just want
to pull up this forbes advisor article
it's not easy being green why esg is
underperforming why is esg on department
2022 i just want to say
if you think investing money
into
anti-meritocratic systems you are a
[ __ ] also because if these
companies were profitable you wouldn't
have to invent something called esg
companies would already be doing the
thing that would make them money and
make them more profitable as a business
you wouldn't have to threaten them with
a bad esg score or incentivize them with
a good one here's the pitch sheamus
we're taking on investors for my company
okay what do we do
we make pizzas yes beautiful now chicago
style who's leading the team
black lives matter of course
what now do they have experience making
pizza no no but their hearts are in
equity right equity i don't look i don't
want my pizza made by someone whose
heart isn't in the right place i hope
you have some women up there at the top
exactly
well hold on what do you mean by woman
not hope mandate yeah someone who
identifies as a woman is good enough for
me yeah
yeah yeah yeah i've always said it's
three six foot five dudes but they've
recently transitioned yeah i've been
wondering why this is kind of related
the trend we've probably all noticed in
the past 10 years which are ads on tv
for products and companies that aren't
telling you about their product they're
telling you what they donate and what
they do and i started asking young
people because it doesn't appeal to me i
don't i don't buy my products based on
that
apparently young people do i was saying
do you care do you care that this
company is spending money advertising to
you or would you rather have advertising
to you about the good that they do in
some social realm or some position they
take or would you rather just have them
sell you the best product at the lowest
price this is a good idea we should do a
commercial for tim cast and have it not
in any way tell anything about that we
were kind of talking about that last
night let's do it yeah for sure we
should let's do what let's do an overly
woke commercial for tim cast and put on
tucker one million i keep saying that
the problem is like we need managerial
power to get these things done like we
want to do the chicken city one
and we're gonna do our pillow and it's
never happened so i don't like talking
about things unless we're like in the
pipeline to do it but projects fall
apart but uh let's do it did you see the
saturday night live skit about that
about the woke commercials and they were
giving the awards for
i was shocked saturday night live did
this it's very funny the most woke
commercials yes you got to look that up
it's very funny about that's the most
shocking thing that they do yes
find it
i will yeah i can't believe snl did
something funny like that's insane
it's funny yeah all right everybody if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
if you really like it because it's the
best way to help the channel grow we're
going to read your super chats
we got a bunch of super chats here
talking about a bunch of crazy stuff so
get your super chats in while you still
can
andre
tuccolescu says f castro jr heartfelt
every canadian
oh man
srenex says since they insist on putting
every shooting that suits their agenda
on national news you should have your
journalists start reporting on every
story they can find of firearms being
used to save lives
that's a good idea actually we should uh
you know create like the list of
self-def of defensive shooting stories
yeah so there's a list yeah there's one
just down the road from us here in west
virginia a little while ago a lady took
on a guy who was about to shoot up a
graduation party i think she took him
out she's a concealed handgun or a
handgun carrier i think i'm not sure if
it's concealed or not but yeah it's
great news no one covers it i just but
don't you know that under the new law
system that that guy the psycho wouldn't
have had the gun yeah exactly right
criminals don't have the guns yeah they
just won't have them yeah no they'll
just all disappear uh i i was looking up
this list and my brain is just so tanked
right now that i googled defensive
self-defense
i was like wait instead of um no gun
stuff but i i've seen
i saw a list a while ago it's kind of a
hazy memory but even so i think would be
good for you guys to report on the
individual stories you know have
journalists reach out to the people talk
to them about it
there i think there's
people probably make running lists of
that yeah i wouldn't be shocked all
right
anthony roman says hey tim i saw one of
your billboards in chicago on my way to
the cubs versus socks game on saturday
here is to keeping up the good work
awesome sweet glad to hear it um i have
no idea it's having an impact because
it's traditional but the idea of
traditional traditional ads is just to
occupy the establishment spaces
there's something interesting about
millennials
they put gen xers and boomers on
pedestals they view these traditional um
elements of civilization as beyond them
it's a weird thing i wonder why that is
you know why is it that people get
prominent on youtube and then view
themselves as not making it like if you
go to these events
i've been to a lot of these there's
constantly a conversation about how we
we are taking over like we are big it's
like you're saying it as though you
don't really think you are right and so
you get these people who have millions
of followers you get hundreds thousands
of views and they're constantly trying
to justify everybody that they actually
are big shows and i'm like you just just
keep doing your thing man
but i think about it in terms of
politics why nancy pelosi is still in
off like still
eight years old diane feinstein all
these joe biden
for some reason
few millennials are engaging at the
highest level of the stuff they don't
own stuff
they they have just a disproportionately
low amount of wealth relative to
previous generations at the same at
their same age they're not engaging in
high-level politics the way the previous
generations were they're just stunted i
suppose they're spending all their time
i just think
all the stuff there is to do online i
mean you guys
maybe you're too young to remember a
time that wasn't like that
i wonder about how much effort has gone
it goes into internal
stuff online that used to go into
inventing things and creating things and
thinking about new things you know
starting a family yeah yeah
all right
mark h says ian if you hear this knock
twice
we want to help you
jose stop it
[Laughter]
i was about to knock and then i saw you
move your hand down i was like
tattered shield says hey tim i'm an
electrician looking to move to west
virginia got any idea of where the best
to move out there
um
i don't know
i need an electrician in virginia a good
electrician there you go northern
virginia
yeah you know we chose this area to the
tri-state because it's close enough to
the big city in the airports so we could
be kind of far away but we're moving
further west into west virginia so
that's being all being built right now
l bossert says if chuck and nancy ban
body armor that will turn every parent
who just bought a bulletproof backpack
into a felon why are they talking about
doing that
is that what's happening didn't they say
something in new york city about banning
yeah that's the only thing that is
there's a supreme court case going
protecting yourself is forbidden really
yeah they also want to take the like
certain body armor away from police and
say you can't if it's in the military
you can't uh refurbish it or give it to
the police that's nuts yes what's the
point i don't get it wow
ywbs pqr says this memorial day i'd like
to also honor those that lost their
lives to experimental procedures
corruption corrupt leadership tax
exposure stock portfolios and suicide
never forget
yeah there's a lot there's a lot of
really bad stuff throughout history man
seriously jk says sheamus membership
sign up doesn't work properly for your
information what's okay so we've
definitely gotten some signups but i can
talk to the web dev people yeah yeah i'm
sorry that it didn't work for you
troubleshooting phase yes we will yes we
are definitely in the troubleshooting
phase
if anyone else is having that problem um
please let me know
i'll i'll leave a comment uh below the
video and you all let me know if you're
having problems with that substance says
brah they got a lot of grizzly bears and
a lot of polar bears in canada and he
just took people's most easiest form of
defense away from them i don't think
polar bears are an issue for canadians
something something about i think way
way way super north yeah but there's
like no one up there moose
looser but you're probably they're up
there working in the syrup mines yeah
that's true every now and again yeah
people don't realize that um up in the
far north of canada in the syrup mines
it's frozen and they have to use a
pickaxe to chip it away and when they
bring it down south where it gets warmer
it naturally just melts in dessert well
like sometimes they actually chip out
frozen cavemen who come back to life and
try to kill them do you know what maple
syrup is made from
uh half maple half syrup right dinosaurs
yeah that's right yes
for the record there are no penguins in
the north pole if you ever see so
they're in the south pole and i went to
antarctica and i learned that fact so if
you ever see them any christmas things
with penguins in the north pole
fake news and also they're in south
america they're not just in yeah they're
on the south yeah yeah so patty going
yeah yeah
yeah yeah you'll see like trees and
stuff with penguins and people don't
realize cause i think penguins are only
on ice or whatever i didn't know that
yeah for the record maple syrup comes
from maple trees but i think you all
knew that is that you're going to get
i'm pretty a warning
maple syrup in the grocery store only
has sugar in it yeah it's not the same
and color caramel color is it even sugar
or is it just corn or is it even corn
syrup with like diet corn syrup with
diet and stuff yeah
and sodium benzoate but you if you if
you buy maple syrup it's maple syrup if
you buy like maple flavored syrup or
like breakfast syrup they call it table
syrup
that's so
nasty it is syrup it's corn syrup it's
heavy that's crazy tastes so good i
heard that when the colonists came i do
agave the native americans saw squirrels
licking trees and so they were like all
right and they cut it open and got the
maple syrup out and then showed
my goodness did they try eating acorns
too
i see a squirrel like something you're
like well i'm gonna try it did you know
how we discovered it you know you can
you can eat maple seeds
maple syrup yeah we call them
helicopters in chicago but then it grows
out of your stomach is the problem you
can't do that yeah you turn into a tree
yeah yeah hello yeah no helicopters yeah
there's all the things that maple
systems what do they taste like i don't
know but we always i always noticed when
i was a kid you'd break them up and
they'd be like a little nut like a
little seed
and they roasted them with like cinnamon
and nutmeg i would just eat them raw you
know i'd pick them up off the ground
catchy that's not right she didn't eat
that helicopter she's dying
all right let's see we got
some more super chats
a lot of people are just yelling at
trudeau and saying words i can't repeat
but okay carter chrisler says army just
awarded sig for contract on the new
rifle chambered in 6.8 so the 556 might
well soon be phased out of the military
really for six eight why why that
why six eight someone's super chat and
tell us give us a good robust
explanation of why
yeah
archimedes says sheamus i just sent you
an article on top of the handgun band
they are moving to shut down independent
media finally yeah i'm i'm so sick of
those independent media people like
lying us into war and spreading
conspiracy theories about work oh wait a
minute
i switched that's that's called the old
bait and switch for anyone who wants
comedy writing tips and tricks
sir lemongrab says tim and cast if the
left and liberals made a rapture
bioshock like place how long would it
take to fail and collapse two weeks
that's it two weeks well yeah how long
did chazz last
remember when there was like an actual
insurrection and left there took over
several city blocks
yeah remember that yeah and there were
sexual assaults and rapes and all sorts
of violence yes all sorts of reasons
that you need a gun exactly yeah um as
well as a as a woman as a biological
woman an actual one
yes says me
uh no guns are an equalizer it's an
equalizer a fourth i mean yeah you could
rest it on my hands but it's i mean
i think it's sexist to try to take away
from women it absolutely helps oh yeah i
agree
oliver tractors has asked cheryl about
fbi threatening her husband
oh
yes so part of the fbi surveillance on
the illegal surveillance that i'm suing
them over now in year x whatever we're
in now
part of what one of the sources who
admitted being part of this operation to
surveil me there were no multiple
operations not just me other journalists
were being surveilled of course
but they
acknowledged they were intending to
plant child porn on my husband's
computer wow
they knew they say they knew we had a
young daughter at home at the time
i mean that blows your mind because that
shows they understand
how did you find that um
one of the federal agents involved you
know through our lawsuits who's spoken
to us has talked about they never
accomplished that part because we
discovered the operation
before i guess it was closed down that
part of it wow we have all the forensics
showing what they did there was no porn
in the computer but that was a discussed
plan according to this one federal agent
and i've mentioned recently when i've
spoken of this that there's a current
lawsuit totally unrelated to anything
i'm talking about now but where a former
fbi agent has admitted that they planted
porn you know on on suspects computers
so
that is anything's possible it's really
and how do how did they get in did they
actually break into the person's house
or with a virus or just
i i don't know in that case but it's so
easy for them with me they have remote
entry to all my devices and computers so
they can operate your computer this is
years ago it's even easier now that they
can come in through your verizon system
your bios line and operate remotely as
if they're sitting in your computer yeah
of course right the nsa can get into
everything basically you can see all
your messages as i was told like things
like butter you know it's not even hard
for them even if you have firewalls wow
what story were you investigating that
led to that well we don't know you know
there were many stories so fast and
furious they accessed that information
in those files in my computer and they
accessed the cbs system proprietary
system during that time period but i was
working on a lot of other stories too
about pharmaceutical industry i was
working on you know republican
corruption stories as well but
i think fast and furious was a big one
then benghazi so there were two at least
two phases of the surveillance on me
there i think they were watching a lot
of um washington journalists at the time
and they probably still are why wouldn't
they wow
all right
legomathagen says if antifa and other
domestic terrorist arms the democratic
party are just an idea and don't exist
yet dems donate money to bail them out
then my tavor 7308 is likewise a social
construct that doesn't exist and i get
to spend money on feeding it
love it there you go there's your way
out good luck
ethan's threat was just an idea yeah
doesn't exist doesn't exist
philosophical concepts it's in minecraft
mini strange cork says she uh says
shamrock sheamus shamrock you just got a
ten dollar sub on freedom love you
support crazy peanut leprechaun peanut
tune makers is that a peanut
oh it's a potato it's a potato
uh i love you i don't love the racism
thank you for the money much appreciated
i really appreciate that we're trying to
uh really get this this running well so
if you guys experience anything i know
one person mentioned they had trouble
signing up just dm me on twitter at
shamus underscore coughlin which is
super easy to spell
um i'm sure it'll be linked in the the
description box that's right whatever
thank you so much for your support by
the way potatoes are indigenous to north
and south america that's true so yeah so
you can't even use that whoever this
this kind subscriber get a new icon
whenever
this is something racist against he's
like no bro i really got you something
cool i'm like it's right it's going to
be racist
why is it because i got you a potato
once it's because
once
every time every time you got me
something except like two times it was a
potato
no that's not true so i found this rare
coin from like oh that it's true two
times no that's so two times what are
you talking what are you talking about i
got you an itunes gift card that's true
but that's two times right the itunes
gift card and uh which is by the way
very nice game and also the potatoes are
nice like i don't turn that down i'm not
it's not like he gives me the potatoes
i'm like this is an insult to my people
we went to a collector's shop and they
had a coin
that is the it's from the uh it's from
the time of jesus christ and they
believe it may have been the coin used
by saint casper and so i was like i
gotta get this for seamus and so i don't
want to tell him what it was because i
was like it's really cool and sheamus
was convinced it was a potato and i'm
like it's not a potato it's like it's
too potato related it's two potatoes
that's right
and then tim's like no it's really good
and then i said and so three what i did
was mashed potatoes when he showed up
french fries instead of handing him the
coin right away i pulled out a packet of
potato paper exactly exactly
it's sheets of potato starch that we got
for a gas jokes on you they were
delicious i'm sure they were
gross oh my goodness all right
seriously jk says first they take your
speech then freeze your money then they
take your guns slowly dismantle your
freedoms via fear threatening the
financial stability of your family while
increasing the reliance of upon the
government
so uh i went to the movies i noticed uh
nobody was there it was kind of crazy
what time did you go it was late at
night really yeah it was like we we saw
it was on eight o'clock showing like
yesterday uh
was it saturday yeah saturday night we
went saturday at two saturday night as
well
i went saturday night also but it was
yeah i think well i went to i they
didn't pay me to say this but there's
it's called the alamo drafthouse cinema
it's like a chain now yeah are they
super dinner
oh i don't i they didn't i didn't see
any of that so if they are then that's
annoying but i didn't see anything it's
uh no but they you it's like dinner you
order you can get drinks and and it was
packed
what's up
gun we went there and it was super empty
which was really weird to me i'm like
where where are the humans like this
buildings were all short staffed the
theater removed all of like the arcade
machines
when we were sitting down waiting for
the movie to start the commercial for
the movie subscription thing comes on
and it's like 21 bucks a month unless it
was like 14 bucks unlimited movies just
show up and i'm like there's nobody here
so are there people who are really like
you know i'm gonna just spend 14 bucks a
month
and i i thought it was weird that
everything is going subscription it was
like 20 something dollars a month right
yeah it was 21 wasn't it and so so for
it to really be worth it i mean for it
to really pay for itself you'd have to
go to the movie three well three times
yeah three weekends out of your life
that's not the issue
the issue is
everything is becoming subscription yeah
and that's all i said right so i tweeted
you know has everyone noticed like
everything's basically subscription
these days and then i get all these
people being like what do you mean
what what's what's your point and i'm
like
that people are embracing something i
don't go to members
by the way you guys go to
freedomtunes.com become a member please
i'm serious
people were like uh
you have subscriptions on your website
what what do you mean and i was just
like
i didn't say not to do it i didn't yeah
it was bad it's a trend i just said it's
kind of crazy like that
i said people are getting used to the
idea of simple deductions in exchange
for just freely available services okay
you brought up my theory now this is why
young people are not going to have
wealth right you watch what they spend
you know what bark boxes are advertised
to get a new box of toys and treats for
your dogs everything and then there's
birchbox which is like i think like
perfume and
and you can see yeah people i'm like you
don't have that kind of money like you
should be saving your money for your
your old age but actually well hold on
well i just want what you're neglecting
is that there are a handful of
millennials who will get really rich
selling that stuff yes i got an idea
hear me out we go to a bunch of
different chain restaurants popular ones
chipotle panda express whatever
and then we create a membership program
where for
50 bucks a month you get unlimited
access to all of these places how do you
provide it
provide what how do you provide the
access to those places
i go to the business and say
you know track and log every person who
comes in and then we pay you a rate
based on total usage
and then what happens is you get a
membership card and you don't got to
worry about paying olive garden or
whatever you show up
and then think about how easy we do
something with groceries you will just
you will just deduct the money on the
first of every month automatically and
everything is just provided to you you
if you need to you fix your car you just
drive with the mechanic you don't got to
worry about paying any money you want to
get food you go to the store and then
here's the best part eventually when we
bet we go belly up because it's an
unsustainable business model we get
subsidized by the government because
we're too big to fail the government
buys up the program and now everyone
excellent i thought this ended up with
like someone getting put against the
wall for opposing the regime i mean i
thought we were doing like
an analogy
it was but i mean that's that's like 10
years down the line yeah yeah what movie
did you see
uh what did we see oh fire starter
that was it good although now i regret
it now i want to see maverick i think
it's a stephen king novel i think
maverick oh my god and i'm not easy to
please on the movies everybody loved it
it was amazing but i don't want to say
that because then if you go expecting
too much yes i just i the reason i
didn't see it because i was like 60 year
old man tries to school young pilots and
i was like and he does baby he does oh
i i like never go to the movies anymore
do you guys go to i mean is it is it
even before but no i know but that was
the first time everybody here everybody
in the room except you went to a movie
this weekend you know what they're doing
now movie theaters because no one's
showing up because you're ironic because
i don't have friends you're poor you're
sorry irish it's because i'm
insufferable oh okay
theaters
are now
movie theaters are not just playing any
movie you'll look and you'll see like
movies from 10 years ago yeah and
they're also allowing screen rentals for
video games and birthday parties
i think we should do the video game
thing like we should that's cool for
sure yeah and we should play
what game should we play i could just be
gt ash bros on
i think some kind of what you might be
getting at at least
thinking about the subscription a lot of
it is like
it's it's surrendering power through uh
suggestion and then also default like if
your life is getting more and more on
autopilot and suggestion in default
you are surrendering more and more of
your decision making which
is for convenience a lot of people do
but i mean i got to be honest if legit
if there was a service where it was like
100 bucks a month and you had unlimited
access to a variety of cars parked all
over the place i totally would get it
there is one actually
uh i think it's called a car
no it's like called
something trouble or i'll look it up but
but and it's like nicer cars like you
can get luxury cars yeah you could like
someone was yeah a friend of mine was
saying they they then you get in a
cadillac and there's a body in the trunk
you're like okay maybe i should have
ubered the problem with a lot of the car
sharing and i could be wrong about this
where it is two-row
yeah okay i know what you're saying what
i mean is like you're walking on the
street and you're like scooters around
town you can just like the scooters
exactly exactly so the scooters all over
the cities i'm sure most people have
seen them you walk up you're in dc i
love the scooters they're they're
awesome people got to be more
responsible with them but you walk up to
the scooter you scan with your phone and
then you just ride
if they did cars that way like you walk
up there's a car and you go oh this
one's good parking yeah it's great yeah
and then you just take the car i'd
totally do it
and then it just like it's very much
like they used to have zip cars i don't
know what they still call them but they
still have them but they're few and far
between i suppose you get the app you
look them up i love that idea you know
so i'm i'm like hey man you know like i
don't i don't i can't stand driving my
car into the city especially in the city
yeah yeah it's just it's annoying
stressful yeah on the country
drive is fun be like me don't get don't
have a car i haven't owned a car since
2011.
all right john king says
terrell lawson ramer san diego county
supervisor and world bank economist put
out a hilarious list of myths on her
website sunlight for disinfectant please
sos
what was it about
who is this that put this up tara lawson
raymer
disco spinach because i thought sheamus
was going to apologize for being back at
the top of the show i demand an apology
for having to deal with him again jk
glad you're back thank you well look i
will apologize for nothing i was working
hard getting this website launched for
you because i love you
and you're gonna super chat tim and
you're not gonna subscribe to my website
that i built for you literally for you
what's his name what's his name again
could you read the name again off the
super chat
i built it for you so go to
freedomtoots.com
and for five bucks a month that's not
that five bucks a month you're gonna get
extra cartoons you're gonna get extra
cartoons there's a bunch of stuff up
there now you'll be supporting
independent content you're gonna love it
you're gonna be very glad for five bucks
a month i get your cartoons you don't
like owning them but you get to watch
extra purchases
exactly i knew what you were trying to
do there give away all your property
pull the wool over my eyes all right
bringer of d says nothing makes me feel
more canadian than following all the
rules only to get punished anyway by
targeted crime prevention initiatives
here's 100 bucks for the crew give a big
f trudeau for me and here's a plug for
the ccfr nfa and cssa canada's gun
rights orgs
right on
nfa
well the nf is the national firearms act
in the united states and that one's a
bad one nfac is very different
all right paulie author says i've
created a website that allows people to
enter in one word at a time articles are
temporary for now but will eventually be
saved to a database it's open for public
testing at polyauthor.com
youtube doesn't allow messages that
sound like dot com
do you wanna you wanna pull that up and
see if it works
do it with my computer the link that
we've never been to before yeah let me
just pull it up on my pc see if it works
what i got a website i'm trying to
launch here oh okay i'm gonna crash my
computer seamus is scared what if i get
a viral what if he's fishing what if i
get a virus tim use your phone
that's great yeah yeah that's good don't
get it won't get a virus on my phone
that's right
you're using
www.patriottruth.wordpress.com.info
dot info that's the name of my new
social media site by the way i know that
i was plugging the freedom team's
website we actually we i have a new
social media company i've just started
called
patriottruthtelling.wordpress.blogspot.truth.net
all right it's a catchy name and we're
hoping wait actually speaking of that
are you guys on truth social
um no no i just joined well i was on the
waiting list for like two months and i
just got off it
and
it's not as good right now as get her
get her has a lot more features you can
go live i know it's way better
you know i like trump so i i
i hope he gets good videos
well i have something i know it's a what
better website it's called
freedomtunes.com and if you go there for
five
cartoon every dollars there are five
cartoons up there now there's behind the
scenes if you're gonna see footage tim
and i improvising videos you're gonna
see time lapses with commentaries about
the videos you're gonna love it it's an
extra cartoon every single week all
right rorschach no says hi cheryl
considering the founding documents of
our country such as the magna carta a
woman's bill of rights isn't that
unusual the sentiments behind the
constitution was due to people of duty
and responsibility wasn't understanding
the notice
that's to carry
yeah carol sherry sherry carroll we're
interchangeable
cheryl
uh
so so the question is well let's just
say that yeah it's a statement yeah no i
women's bill of rights dot com please go
there
and you can put your name on there i
know a lot of people have their
usernames this is you know if you want
to put your your real name out there um
say that you support women biological
women uh and
we're introducing this we've already
introduced it on capitol hill and we're
going to take it to a state near you too
uh well i i i know we'll be more
successful in certain states than others
i'm already talking to people from a
couple states uh with their governors
who are very interested in this so
it's really pathetic that this has to be
happening
now it's like uh cavemen cavemen
uh or you know tribal bedouin tribal
societies they knew what a woman was but
we don't you know it's like we can put
someone on the moon but we can't define
a woman all right
one small step for
what's what's a man
personhood personhood yeah exactly it
has the word son in it so i'm sorry all
right let's read some more we got dang
he says hi tim i recently graduated from
uni with a ba in comms and i want to
work for you i'm a tv producer engineer
with two and a half years of experience
six years of video editing experience
six years of voice acting experience
play three instruments i'm fluent in
russian dank send an email to tim p at
timcast.com which instruments
[Laughter]
i play uh the guitar the acoustic guitar
the acoustic electric guitar
and the bass drums piano clarinet
i play the synth the drum machine zither
the uh the triangle
which is what it is
i actually do play the drums and
actually i play guitar bass and drums
but guitar and bass it's like if you can
play guitar you can play bass
i mean not necessarily if you can like
slap and stuff that's different skill
set from strumming but you know
yeah
role models are really offensive to
basis by the way you're probably gonna
get in trouble for that well like a real
bass player
they can legit play the bass
but someone who plays a guitar can play
the bass just doesn't mean you're gonna
you're not gonna be good at it right
you'll be good enough at it because like
anyone can play a bass but not be good
at it right like anyone could play any
instrument no i mean like if you can
play guitar you can pick up the bass and
play bass for your band
but you want a real bass player who's
like got you know good writing skills
true romol says i'm an engineer for sig
sauer the army wanted a projectile and
rifle that is capable of penetrating
body armor at long ranges
the advancement and level 4 armpit makes
it much easier and lighter to use love
y'all
interesting
all right spirofluoropolis says um so
i've messaged about sources say online
three times now any love for that
same as that website one word at a time
uh well right on well to check out
sources.online and see what it's all
about sources say dot line looks way
better than polyauthor.com just saying
oh
we got it we had a fight happening all
right we'll check it out but if you
haven't already you got to smash that
like button subscribe to the channel
share the show with your friends head
over to timcast.com and become a member
we're gonna have that members only show
coming up it'll be published in just
about an hour and it's uh it's not
family friendly we swear a lot it's uh
the after dark show not not for your
kids so um after hours what do you mean
we swear a lot tim you swear a lot i do
swear i'm perfectly well behaved on the
other
side
so much so head over there check it out
you can follow the show at tim cast irl
follow us on instagram because we post
clips throughout the day on instagram so
at tim cast irl you can follow me on
twitter and instagram tim cast cheryl
did you want to shout anything out
cheryl atkinson.com also i'm giving out
an independent journalism cash award
cool call the ion awards i've already
done it to journalism schools but not a
professional journalist for off
narrative reporting if you know anybody
today's the last day maybe tomorrow to
enter go to cherylackson.com read more
because trying to encourage people to do
reporting more the old-fashioned way
like we used to so um how many people
it's it's a uh was it 20 people when the
pulitzer every year
i don't even know that's the print
awards i think it's 20 people and they
get 15 000 each for a pulitzer so i've
been talking with some people we have a
non-profit for fact checking and i think
we're going to start doing awards
because that's brilliant i'm giving 3
000 to the students and 3 000 for the
professional of my money which to
journalists as a young journalist that's
a lot of money to me you know that's
nice and they cannot i judge the emmys
every year
and they still let you do that yeah
those prayers are some great good for
you there's some great entries every
year from almost every news organization
they're just not always prominent
stories but isn't it
but it's well it's
as someone who's received quite a few
emmys myself not always i hope but it's
the same it tends to be the same 10
stories over and over year after year if
you know what i mean like the same
foreign stories with the same themes
even the same domestic stories by
different reporters and some of it's
very good reporting but it's very on the
narrative and if you do anything that's
not these days
off if you do anything that's not on the
narrative you're not going to win any of
those awards so i'm trying to recognize
some of those it needs to be what we
want to do is
you don't need to apply for it
so that's like the enemies you apply for
it don't you yes yeah i use organization
or whatnot i that that feels fake to me
to be honest you know so having worked
in corporate press it's like now submit
to us what you think is worthy and you
have to pay a fee yes yeah
yeah they have full-time people and
that's their job is to apply for awards
for the news outlets right yeah when i
worked they were they had people on
staff and it was like make sure you're
submitting and paying the fees and i'm
like so they make a bunch of money off
the fees and then too and then give it
to the person they think is better it's
like that's gambling to me
the only difference is like if you're
not in the club you don't win it's oh
and it's never retracted like all those
pulitzers who went for all of the russia
skates what we're going to do is one day
you as an independent journalist or uh
reporter will get an email saying we've
selected you as the winner you needed
nothing to do we just thought you did a
good job and we want you to keep doing
it so uh
the one thing we're waiting on right now
is all the paperwork's filed we're just
waiting for
filing status to like be formalized we
filed a while ago i love it but um there
are a lot of people who are interested
in helping fund the the project and i'm
just like cool
we will see a journalist who's on the
ground and we'll we're going to have an
award ceremony and we'll explain why we
chose this person and i'm and we'll
probably end up picking people who won't
like us they're going to be like i'm not
coming but we thought you did a good job
so you deserve it but uh yeah anyway uh
carrie did you want to show anything out
oh yeah uh women's bill of rights.com
and then i also started a sub stack uh
and it's carrie sheffield.substance.com
very cool
uh i don't really have anything for
ronaldo
[Laughter]
if you guys want to go over to my
youtube channel freedom tunes we make
cartoons i think you guys will enjoy
them we also have a website we just
launched freedomtunes.com if you
subscribe and become a member five bucks
a month you'll get extra cartoons you'll
also be supporting independent content
that goes against what the establishment
wants you to believe
very cool i might have to go check out
what's going on on this uh crazy weird
new website that james keeps pushing for
some reason you guys may follow me on
twitter mines.com sarpatchlitz as well
as
sourpatulits.me we will see all of you
over at timcast.com thanks for hanging
out
you